you get perfect
[Music]
perfect move on and move your your arm
back that way
your mic not your actual arm sorry
[Laughter]
let's get it towards you a little more
right there yeah yeah cause it was going
past him you know
as we start let's restart quick one a
quick one all right cool hold on here we
go start it up
you sit cool
this is the coolest Setter we ever had
yeah
here we go shut up dude didn't have a
lot does that unlock on it yeah
I don't like to sit low this is lift
your chair up you only just sit low you
were slouching that's the low rider
brought in dude they don't have the
[__] lock on it then just sit forward
sorry for my kid okay let's let's you
know what let's just go straight into
the intro let's go hey what's up guys
what up there we go here we go hey
what's up no let's start it over
actually are you two dope as y'all here
hope you're having a dope ass day
welcome back to adobe's usual podcast
I'm with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys what's up guys today we have a
very special episode Hall of Fame NFL
wide receiver Tim Brown in the studio
what's up man how you doing
all right so OG's back and guys we've
been trying to start for 40 minutes
we're almost two hours late this is
great I love it how you feeling Good
Feeling Good yep yes sir do you get a
lot of sleep
uh yeah sure did you sure sure you did
yeah I did I was at your house till two
in the morning we're talking about yeah
you should I didn't wake up till 10.
okay nevermind take it back all right
take it back Marty was up until seven
this morning
damn filming yeah we're at 3 30 a.m call
time downtown son out there slinging
that thing
oh you're a hooker bro 3 30 downtown out
there slanging that thing you realize
what you said okay yeah thank you sir
that's right so how you feeling huh I'm
feeling good you like the Raiders
sure okay let's share
you get them season tickets shout out in
Vegas uh no I don't get no season
tickets oh no she's they know me bro
I'll just go when I go
he always gives the guy at the front 20
bucks and then they kick him out so say
for sure damn speaking of football
[__] ran about real quick you see the
new Madden cover
uh no actually you know you know what
you did post it right and I didn't see
it wait but you posted but she said he
posted but you know I didn't pay
attention who the dude was that's what
it was oh that's different that's
different I didn't pay attention who was
it trash out oh [__] bills oh did you
see the cover damn the the graphic
artist broke down do you see it I one of
the bars that's what I'm about to whine
about all right first of all they put
the bills on the cover and I start
getting all these messages
I don't know nothing yeah we've been
hacked since the 90s no the Madden Curse
is real oh let's hope Josh Allen
overcomes that because he's from the
Central Valley let's go I mean you think
you think he's gonna be hurt this year
hope not is it an injury style curse
every single year oh all right you know
what no there was one that didn't get
one right there was one year that did it
was recent it was a recent recent one
yeah recently yeah it was me
is me they put out the franchise version
of it they got the one the main version
of the artwork it's cool it's all blue
it's got him holding his jersey like
this right oh yeah and then they put out
like the deluxe version where it's him
in the stands in the crowd and it's a
cool shot like the way they did it I'll
put it up over the screen here there's
some cool depth of field going he's all
in the stands and it's cool it
represents the Bills fans cool can't
break his neck this year
all right
they did a goddamn Photoshop blunder on
my random cover
of man there's a Photoshop mess up they
put really an extra bar on his helmet
right here that wait what do you mean
you're the face mask the bars that come
across okay there's a bar he's he's like
that so he wanted to see his mouth so
they erased the bar from his mouth only
up to here so there's a floating half
bar right by his face on the cover of
the video game oh [__] so it's a [__]
scenario oh big big [__] time save it
right put it this way if I post an
Instagram you're like hey Marty actually
messed up here can we do that not send
it to production do you know how many
people had to pass that I had to get
past that yeah yeah so so that's gonna
be worth some money maybe in the future
no because they're all messed up oh
that's the print oh they posted that
it's done
by the way it would have made only about
100 of them then it would have been
included
yeah it's mad that's right yo is John
Madden alive no no passed away when he
passed away a few years ago very quietly
quick like recently uh yeah I want to
say yeah
nobody really says [__] about it oh no
it was out there I didn't really see
much about it you ain't a true Raider
fan oh oh that's what I forgot he was
what the red is yeah but for being such
a legend and for so relevant and just
culture for the video game he must have
did something
it was good no nothing creepy I'm just
saying he must have hit somebody off go
you know I know you're a big part of
this whole thing he's like they Pete
rosed him yo we're not gonna really
mention you much no no people because he
was doing that I know that but I'm
saying the way they did it was like why
is John Madden not part of the NFL
anymore oh no he's big bro what do you
mean but you remember he was the
announcer then just one day gone and
nobody talked about him again
right
what is it sounds like Mario's leveling
up sounds like the phone I thought it
was the I thought it was the camera
turning off that's why I've been looking
back like oh the camera's shut off
and um yeah no John Mann just kind of
disappeared anyway we get the smoke weed
um I have I have everybody refer to
Yola's Snapchat for what we have here
because the [__] is astonishing and our
Twitter at dope as usual there we go
got a bunch of joints rolled up took
them like five hours to roll those oh it
took him at five hours to get here for
me so here we go we got all these these
are one strain from some guy from UK and
this is from cbx the stuff that smells
just like Jack dry hit that
wait so it's not Jack it's not Jack oh
[__] bro
that's like 2012 Jack fire packs really
I'm gonna have to try it
like Jack we need to invest in a
microscope around here so we can get to
the bottom of these Terps
is that you guys's phone
I hear is it in my headphones
I keep hearing like a Mario yeah I know
I hear it too right it's OG's phone he
just put it in his pocket check my phone
and see if I have a message I don't all
right all right just making sure here we
go let's get started Let's get high so
we rolled some weed up today
I may or may not make you get really
high today we'll see that's Emoji right
here all right both of them but at the
same time yeah for sure okay let's start
this one up first
start it up you got one nice all right
let's get into one topic I want to get
into with this weirdo right here you
ready
you ready
what are you gonna ask me [__] is
something I forgot is It Something I
Said is it American history yeah yeah
for real who was the first president
yeah right that's what yeah right how
about this how about the vice president
came out at a basketball game I was at
recently uh-huh what would her name be
vice president
homegirl uh what is that weird old chick
um what's her name [__]
um Kamala yeah I was like it sounds like
some [__] like that I had to question
who she was I had to look at my kid like
vice versa vice president
what it's like the year of bad drafts
yeah like all these quarterbacks are
okay they got no Flair I mean they're
not memorable sure that's how I feel
with this presidential thing also I
don't care about uh the uh politics at
all what I was gonna ask you
hey Light That Joint bat oh you're on it
never mind
what I was going to ask you is aliens
aliens
aliens we were saying earlier alien
videos are becoming so common it's
almost like uh something you scroll past
I don't even stop and look at it because
my which ones are faked don't care not
gonna sit here and decipher I think it's
just there's more things going on now
and that's they're just trying to bring
that up now so it's just a little
distraction a little distraction the
biggest thing ever aliens for sure now
you're just gonna say it well we already
got [__] aircrafts that [__] move
like that bro
we're like [__] what 50 years
Advanced hey what's up with the three
years whole world media covering a damn
balloon exactly I didn't even know what
happened till someone told me because I
saw like 50 I'm going to scroll I do not
care at all couldn't care less actually
yeah
a balloon I see balloons all the time
which one's from China why
why do you think it's trying to mix
everything
they made the plastic balloon is that
what you try to say I was racist I made
tick tock that was funny the [__] I
heard about it yeah I don't know bro I'd
fall into that there's like a stupid orb
going through the air it's like a little
life bar in a video game I'm cool no
thanks this Swedish there was a real
stretch where uh my mom thought when
Google Street View was brand new like it
was really new still
it had a little light flares like if you
were to pan up to the sky you might
catch a couple Crazy Light flares in
certain frames
my mom damn near had me convinced that
was some [__] aliens for a minute I
beat oh yeah you never know you never
know looking at them from different
Vantage points on the street view and
[__] seeing if
perspectives the same light flares look
like [__] aliens yo real quick we'll
talk about Google Earth
Justin from Texas you know Justin talked
about him many times
shout out this fool a Google Earth and
they drove by his house and he didn't
know this was out there with little like
just basketball shorts no shirt
Shoe list like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
no no Just Dance
right and you see his truck next to him
oh bro this is so good he's like Google
Earth my house this is [__] did you
see the the video he sent me the UFO
video yeah he took yeah in El Paso El
Paso Texas hospital was actually pretty
dope I posted on one of my other pages
that I got are you a full page sick what
was it this is a UFO
oh do you see some [__] out here so now
that aliens are out and about we're
talking about them tell me your craziest
UFO story that you've seen
I mean no no no no no no come on tell me
one
I don't want to be no [__] little
meme before you're talking about [__]
hey we see [__] in the sky all the time
people are on TV now showing you yeah I
mean it sounds stupid talking about so
one time I was at OG's house and we're
in the backyard smoking joints and this
fool looks up he goes look at that
horror before and that's when I realized
that oh wow that's what I'm looking at
and we saw these things like dancing
around each other for 30 minutes and
he's like look look and it was like
light in the middle of the day it was
changing color it was so odd bro it was
moving as if someone had a laser pointer
very very drastic quick movements and
then another one came up behind that
cloud it was high asses standing out
there
staring at it for 30 minutes straight it
was pretty wild because I've told you
about the [__] I've seen
wild ass random ass lights you out needs
to use there's your for some reason your
neighborhood's so bright at night
it's always bright even last night we
were smoking your backyards do you
notice that
the lights behind that is always bright
like it's dark though I've noticed that
in the sky like the sky is pink never
dark yeah it's never dark yeah what time
well you know one time um
we're out there looking at UFOs whatever
we ended up uh taking off I took off
[__] um when to go eat you know
came back everybody in my blog said hey
bro some weird [__] light was just on
top of your house
like just right on top of your [__]
house
and everyone thought oh [__] okay it was
a fire rating
hell no it was just one [__] light
and just [__] took off like gone
crazy not like I'm not saying right
above my house you know what I mean but
[__] like like Independence Day
basically what I mean some crazy [__]
and I was like oh damn trip out there's
hella [__] out here in L.A we see yeah
weird lights and random objects in the
sky all the time bro I see it a lot yeah
you see a lot if you go you'd be
surprised bro if you just if you just
stick around outside and look up and
several you can put your phone out
overnight guys time lapse it get shocked
in the morning yeah I've had some [__]
on my phone that I didn't even know I
had I just found some [__] oh [__] I
just found some [__] um
just two days ago that I recorded in
2016 that I didn't even know and I'll
just [__] filming up and just a
couple days ago I was looking for some
you know for some [__] you know some
content to post on my page
and I was like oh damn what the [__] is
that that just flew by a [__] posit
bro and did you see it like
like what the [__] trippy [__] do you
think in a couple 50 years from now do
you think that's it's gonna be normal
like uh Men In Black style like
intertwining with humans type [__] yeah
yeah for sure 100 I mean you just had
some people in Vegas just yesterday
right scrolled right past it you did I
watched that end of signs movie well I'm
just saying you yeah you have people now
trying to talk about it and be more open
about it now you see the cops you know
when would a cop every cop would [__]
go to your pad be like what did you see
oh [__] we've seen it you know it's
usually like they'll tell you yeah right
you're full of [__] you're on drugs so
now it's just like it's out there now
it's it's somebody that's well known is
going to come out and buy Brahm an alien
and that's how it's gonna get accepted
well I believe that we already have them
within it that's what I'm saying
someone's gonna say something yeah I
think the world is kind of like X-Men
and once you get exposed to certain
things
certain things could be like leaked out
that you had in your brain already does
that make sense like you know when
people go through certain trauma [__]
and they're like yo I'm Different I
[__] been saying [__] like I [__]
hallucinate like I don't know if you're
hallucinating are you seeing other [__]
you know what I'm saying when people go
through wild [__] what if it's like a
break
if you can do a certain part like this
guy oh you you almost drowned this
[__] could fly in water I don't
know I think of the world is
accidentally I guarantee there's some
monks out there like you're gonna fly
through the forest I'll be back can
unlock shut I the monks that are
meditating for 40 hours and try I
believe that those foods go leather
there's got to be some point tonight I
believe it because they always talk
about they can [__] levitate off the
ground one during meditation like do
they live longer I don't know but I feel
like something well then again they
don't we don't know we can't go in there
well I mean come on I mean who built the
[__] pyramids and all that [__] those
are some big ass bricks from [__] you
know it was something different that was
going on back then big bricks how many
of you don't use more of our brain and
now you know it took he took some of
that from us because the chemicals so
now we just use now [__] what the part
of our brain was besides of a p right
almost or that we really use the size of
the dime these days that's what we know
that's you know that's what we are
that's what you use for now imagine back
then you probably use your whole brain
you could move [__] I believe that [__]
the government did all that remote
viewing in the 70s I mean and I believe
sometimes it happens when you're in a
room and then um [__] just falls out of
nowhere I believe that's your energy bro
people say oh there's goals no it's
[__] your energy that just [__]
move that [__] because you know just a
different part of the mind it did not
work
watch this oh it's a lot harder than
that
if that [__] really happened I'd bounce
bro
I could probably Photoshop that up
it just pauses
so that was a terrible terrible UFO
story
I went to the store came back and
someone said that there was a UFO
[__] that was whack
you're gonna say you saw no I mean I
heard there was a light once
no I mean like I said there's a lot of
[__] I mean I've been outside but like
once I bought this telescope you know
I'm [__] just to [__] check out
[__] all right [__] it was a
telescope with the laser
really went out there with a lady wanted
the laser up and we're like I want to
see if I can see what that started oh
like a scope yeah what does the laser do
hey it's supposed to like help you
[__] point like what star you want to
put in your points
I like that so you know [__] we did
that [__] [__] um next you know bro
bam because here they come
[__]
passing by pretty fast bro I'm not
saying lights yeah it's like one big
boom ball like this is [__] moving
like at a speed that you're seeing
through the telescope
after that you just see it they're just
going by and you're like what what is it
about East L.A in that area over there
well you know I do live under a fly zone
[Music]
okay so for some reason yeah there's
always weird shapes and even like when
we start even when we go out there and
we see you know um when I start seeing
UFOs and [__] out then you know [__]
I just see the planes helicopters start
passing by [__] some weird not just
they're usually helicopters some
different type of [__] [__] planes
and helicopters start passing by and
they're really up high and I'm oh [__]
it says one [__] that just passed by and
they're [__] watching it you know
what I mean it's crazy you know I mean
you see a lot of [__] and you you've
seen a lot of [__] I've seen some [__]
so you know what I mean so I'm not
[__] making this [__] up you know
what's crazy is to think is what about
the fools that are flying that and go
home and be like yo no today I was just
you know helicopter pilot a little do
they know like their wife like I chase
down two ships today we caught one like
yo that's a life that you have to take
to the Grave you can't talk about it
like wow I was watching that guard in
the Galaxy movie like that fool can
never come back to earth like yo I work
at Walmart Supercenter I was just
shooting aliens three years ago like
that's whack that would just never come
yeah you're you get flashy thing flashy
thing yeah I think you do get flashy
thinged
Men In Black is real all right I feel
like that shit's wild getting closer to
that getting closer to Men In Black a
lot closer
yep I believe it's all real oh yeah for
sure I believe some more athletes might
be
a little strange I'd [__] give it to
Luca if anybody who's that if I could
the white dude on the Nuggets
yes I don't know anybody yeah and I know
that like oh that one white dude
he's the nude Dirk yeah
I don't know any basketball players
hello
Kyrie Irving still play it I think so
who Kyrie Irving no I don't think that's
I know that guy he's dope
Bros I wasn't Pete Rose what's his name
he's a good rose no Dylan Rose thank you
sorry it is
on your own answer that was right my bad
oh gee he doesn't watch sports
where's your Raiders tattoo do you have
one no you sure Mindy's you got a
Raiders tattoo oh she shook her okay
I'll get it soon but yo ready within two
minutes no no he's gonna do it in 10
seconds within 30 seconds how does the
Raiders turn it around and win the Super
bowl next year
same [__] every year it's so big I knew
it was going to be 10 seconds gotta
[__] just like I mean hey you know
what hey [__] we do have [__] then
Tom Brady but he's part of it now too I
heard what are you tired of the Raiders
didn't he [__] huh D retired sir no
no no no I said he bought part of the
Raiders no he's not playing for the
readers he bought part of the Raiders
yeah isn't he or some [__] like that
yeah you heard you read well I mean I
read you know and I don't know you know
she's full of [__] but I'm pretty sure
yeah it's real yeah he did that's badass
Raiders suck
[Laughter]
agreed to a deal to acquire a minority
stake damn Tom Brady's in minority now
yo 25 years ago nuts man you don't play
football I don't know what's next that's
what I'm saying I mean Vegas is gonna
have to take one man I'm telling you
they're gonna have to win one regardless
everything's fixed now man I don't
[__] now that I see it it's
everything's [__] fixed bro you know
I don't really watch football because
after I saw the one clip on YouTube it's
like is the NFL fixed and I saw like
three clubs there was a clip of the
Niners the Niners cornerback going to
make a tackle and then just
like his controller went dead just
stopped and was like ah you should score
second quarter it's not like he needed
to yeah
I think everything's rigged already bro
did they go in there go guys if you lose
tonight 40K in cash for all you guys in
there I was just letting you know and
you know for all we know it's always
been rigged bro but just back there we
didn't realize and you know just people
are just seeing more because you got
more cameras they were smoking
cigarettes back then they were really
playing yeah no not only that but they
was in cameras it wasn't cameras like
like there is no no you got everybody in
the damn [__] hospital with the
camera recording and everything so
that's how you catch [__] NBA refs like
facial expressions yeah you see that
[__] too right yeah okay that's what I'm
saying you know what I mean so I mean
but I mean yeah rage is going to be
taking one person just because I know
it's all fixed and [__] taking one of
what reference like like winning
something or like Super Bowl for sure
yeah okay all right I think they'll have
the first pick in the draft next year
just to say even if they did bro we got
the first pigs we still [__] suck oh
[__] JaMarcus Russell I always want
the Raiders from California but the
disappointment's so bad that I just give
up like you like the Raiders manual stop
it they're my second favorite yeah so
you see so what the [__] they're my
second team yeah I love the Raiders
they're California or Niners besides we
got the best colors
whatever I mean yeah okay I mean what's
even happening right now what are we
talking about how about this on a scale
from one to ten how badly I beat the
[__] out of here how about that
what was the last chord can you remember
the last score when we played
I remember the last guys we played the
last time I ever played was two years
ago do you remember the last score uh
yeah you probably might have wanted to
have one year too you probably beat me
15 times out of maybe a hundred
I'm not gonna say boo she did beat me
outside but you know what I mean [__]
come out of this man really with the
Packers
no I only play with the Panthers oh only
Cam Newton and and uh McCaffrey can't
stop me I'm gonna run it through it I'm
gonna throw and run it
you don't know which one's coming
in a minute
the last time I probably when we used to
play last time I played you was the last
time this is something that needs to
happen with like some steaks it's fun I
wanted to do a series called play
remember I told you playing rappers in
Madden for QPS hmm like yo here's a QB
let's [__] play this [__] damn all
right cool let's go I didn't realize you
were that confident I forgot I'm not
good at man I just want to play the game
it sucks yeah like he's a trash
um I don't really play video I mean I
play with my team I play with the
Raiders though you know I mean yeah okay
so yeah yeah I don't pick no other team
when I play football that's not true
that's like royalty then we started
switching it too I mean my second team
is probably the Saints yeah [__] okay
but I mean but that's
you know but you know my second team to
go to would be probably be the Saints
throw up now I was thinking about this
while I was editing uh Thomas's latest
video where he heroically
picks out the [__] nuggets and places
them on the scale and calls oh I I
bought the amount of Zips in the [__]
video today I went oh I could do this no
there that's 28. this is three
competition eyeball and peas I did that
in a video a long time ago not as good
as that as I thought I'd say you guys do
a heads up battle we start at like
ounces or whatever half ounces you do a
heads up challenge each time you have
faith
Ace by Ace by Ace base bro eighth I'll
probably hit this thing it's funny you
know we talk about that [__] you know
the other day just yeah just a few weeks
back you know what I mean
I was like you know I was getting some
bud and [__] and um for one of my
friends you know he's like oh bro we
need to get something good something you
know I'm gonna get Bud
this was a [__] lagging on me bro I'm
just I don't have a second I go [__] I
don't have this [__] patient bro I
saw so much weight I don't even have the
patience to sell weed anymore um
like bro you're here bro just [__]
whatever we split it go cool bro but I
don't have the patience for this oh you
bought weed and together yeah we split
it yeah
I was like I have the patience for this
[__] bro no more you know what I mean
and it's just like [__] bro I guess bro
it's just it's just to me it's just not
I don't know bro that shit's like boring
to me yo listen to this I don't have the
patience to illegally sell weed anymore
but he legally sells two patients
which is funny yeah like I don't have
the patience but I have patience
I don't sell [__] to nobody I'm in the
back I know funny thinking about it like
patience for this [__] yeah I don't bro
honestly
I really [__] don't bro I don't I
don't think I have the pictures to
[__] to sell pounds no more like I
did before you know what I mean we're
just waiting on people having to text
people
I mean never love it too many years bro
I did it for over 20 years and so just
[__] over that [__]
on the other side as the customer I
don't miss that trip
I [__] hated having to deal with a
[__] guy that's the other side I hate
you you see how lady was today what if
you're buying a [__] zip from this
guy back then don't worry with no cell
phone service it was a beeper you get
weed every week this food doesn't show
for five days every other day I'm trying
to meet him for a nickel bag oh yeah
Marty was that guy by nickels and dimes
he said when I moved here's the
dispensary imagine
what the [__] he went all the way to the
shop to buy it 10 seconds that's not
even worth the gas
yeah
I had to get I get some [__] some
people like that but not everyone's
getting taken care of quick we're
talking about the shop oh no I'm talking
about [__] yeah exactly what are you
saying though yeah he used to just pick
up a nickel every so you're saying you
beat Thomas in a heads-up battle just
eyeballing eyeballing weed I think we'd
be so close I think I think it'd be so
good I think I probably can you get
eyeball he can weigh money better than
me though but he's the first person to
ever saw weight Stacks I was like what
are you [__] on a scale yeah so well
this means this like oh you're you're a
genius I've never seen that before I
never never waited I only uh I only
count so much [__] so much fun I'm
telling you bro from trapping so much
before it just like
damn bro every time I go here you need
to count this money and [__] wrong just
like [__]
hit or hey guys she's um
[__] man so you're not gonna [__] this
[__] go give me a stack I started
waiting on Stacks I'm like hell no boom
let's [__] do it like this and Bam I
just start waiting no it's crazy it's
down to the to the ground but the thing
is the reason why like all these fools
in the comments get a money counter a
money counter in your home is another
charge
it's not even worth it yeah it's not
even worth having the money counter if
you have like weed types if you're
trapping it out you have money counters
like oh I'm pretty sure yeah it's not
gonna look good to the judge you got
money you got phones you got a [__]
money counter yes that makes it all look
like a [__] all right you're [__]
yo operation our homie
[Music]
yeah well let's break it out bleep the
word out our homie you know yeah I
remember when he he was one of the first
fools when I was selling packs of Merced
that was
selling packs like you know
oh my yo so how much of these you got
like I got like 600 right 600.
[Music]
you know it's Boutique up north cookie
packs like those are 34 but you have
600. damn you're about to crush it and
that's the first time I was like wow
you're really moving away that's awesome
let me get like 50. you know or whatever
it was and uh he's the first person he
was complain I've never heard anybody
complain about money in my life he was
like these [__] the prices fool they
don't [__] with the money counters and
like they always count it by hand takes
[__] hours
damn it break that out
got it or just cut that line I actually
say his name
like dude you're complaining about
counting money you're complaining about
count he's like you don't get it you
don't understand a 400 000 in 20s go
give it to me right now I would love to
do it a lot and he's like no I bought
money counters for all these Mexican
fools in the hills and now they love it
they don't want to go back my girl did
they never heard of a money counter they
never once tried to get a [__] money
counter like that's the craziest thing
but that's the first time I ever heard
somebody like this [__] hurts my fingers
I thought that was just rappers like
flexing like my thumbs heard from
counting on like no that [__] sucks this
gets so violently deathly sore it hurts
bro you can't even like grip the [__] I
only did that one time I was like I'm
not doing that again but my friend he
can play him like you're complaining
about money
that's real yeah money counters are free
More Money More Problems yeah I didn't
have money Connor never got a money
Connor neither it was a [__] it was a
hassle but at the same time it's it was
fun back then again it's fun I like
Circle money when you're doing in
circles I [__] love that [__] not
only that but like I mean I'll tell you
the truth I don't think wait maybe I
didn't always caught the money I think I
never did count it the money you counted
it 100 minutes that was fun I already
got the money that's what I was like I
used to do he's doing the car on trips
hey man you had one job it'd be the
backpack full of money I'd count a stack
while I'm driving pass it to Rosie for a
double count past the original double
count rubber Bandit rubber Bandit
remember remember that [__] years
driving with my knee just
or when trucks come by move lanes
because they're gonna look and go what
the hell is going on in there be [__]
floorboard full of money that was fun
times man it was fun I used to just like
going in there hearing the number all
right what do we got 36
all right I'll be back right now cool
over there so where are we at now oh
we're at 56. all right cool I'll be back
and [__] let's just go up it's a
video game 80 rocks and [__] damn all
right good [__] it was a good [__]
fun time
good day good day as well it's not worth
it no more
you can't make no money off weed no more
it's crazy [__] I hear from homies that
still do [__]
no and you know what they're still doing
it no we're still doing the numbers
no they are but but
um same [__] I mean what's what's going
on is that you know everybody from
Becky's everybody's you know that's like
there's still money to be made but like
for us you know I mean it's just more
like already like I mean the way I like
it is like ah [__] I don't care about
making 100 bucks or 200 [__] out of here
but it used to be like how would you
make 50 Cent oh nice okay
[Music]
and then you start putting math again
like wow that's 5K real quick
yeah she used to make me High I mean
still I mean he does it it does I'm
about to flip this table right now I
know that's how I feel flip it but make
it land again yeah yeah and not spoil
the ashes oh the ashes will not spill if
anything there's gonna be there gonna be
more like you asked why you were doing
it like that
like Jumanji let's get back on topic
um what were you even talking about
actually
money counters first I've ever heard
somebody complain about money because
when you said I'm like wow complaining
about counting money it is a job
when you drop trapping it out it's like
[__] dude
that [__] took four hours [__] and you
don't realize like I have to drive still
like oh it's been four hours no no and
then you get there and then [__] the
next person wants to count it you're
like [__] all right okay now you can't
see you know so [__] it you'll be sick
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our sponsors and
this is hellofresh if you don't already
know about hellofresh let me break it
down to you really quick you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep there is a reason why
hellofresh is America's number one meal
kit it allows you to skip the long
tedious grocery store trips hellofresh
makes home cooking easy affordable and
fun this summer hellofresh has gone
above and beyond to really make eating
well easy calorie smart protein smart
lunches along with brand new vegan
recipes Rosie and I are actual customers
of hellofresh and let me say it for me
to you if you uh have a significant
other maybe picking what you want to eat
may take forever hello fresh and all the
ingredients for the meal for the meal 25
less than the average takeout menu all
you do is go to hellofresh.com forward
slash yola16 and use the code checkout
Yola 16 and no matter what you do
signing up you just want to try it out
16 free meals delivered to your door
just because you watch the podcast on
top of the 16 free meals using our code
you get free shipping it doesn't get any
easier if you wanted to take that step
now is the time once again go to
hellofresh.com forward slash yola16 use
our code yola16 at checkout 16 free
meals plus shipping thank you guys so
much for supporting the brands that
support us
I know you've noticed it from the gas
pump to the grocery store to streaming
to playing games inflations everywhere
everything costs more thankfully there's
one company out there trying to save
people money and that's mint mobile as
the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
has allowed you to order from your home
save a bunch of money and get phone
plans as little as 15 a month by going
online only mint mobile has allowed
themselves to go around the cost of
normal retail and pass all the savings
directly onto the customer all of mint
Mobile's plans come with unlimited talk
text plus high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network mint
mobile has made it easy and seamless to
transfer over right now using your own
phone you can get any mint Mobile plan
keeping your same phone number and all
of your existing contacts the dope as
usual podcast has officially teamed up
with mint mobile bringing the savings to
you right now go to mintmobile.com Yola
and you can get your plan starting at
just 15 a month Everyone likes to save
money cut your wireless bill down to
just 15 a month using mint mobile once
again go to mintmobile.com Yola and as
always guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode
I want to see you hit that joint I don't
think you've hit it today well this
[__] joint is burning slow it's nice
and sticky perfect good weed I'm telling
you it's the guy from London
from London no this was OG he wrote them
oh okay never mind we didn't almost [__]
this one next let's move another one
so what's what's been your most recent
mushroom experience
you know what uh [__] I mean I think
that's kind of almost
maybe like
the most recent one but I saw you
chopped down those uh Taffy bars right
yeah I was like I took I took yeah
they're pretty good yeah they're pretty
good those were like what they were like
some uh the ones you gave me the micro
dose ones oh do you like them yeah
they're pretty good yeah man they're
okay I don't know which ones they are
you know right after maybe an hour after
you take them smoke they'll kick them in
you know you kind of double it a little
bit with the smoking yeah they're pretty
good though I mean
I like micro dosing better I think
[Music]
it's [__] it's been a while since you
went real deep with the show yeah you
know you got too much [__] going on I
can't forget you know I can't [__]
[__] put my head straight with that
[__] Bro oh geez dog is racist
with my dog writer's racist right it's
almost night yeah really yeah towards
Mexican people no I'm kidding
I was just thinking about riding in
Miami Rider a long time and I saw him
last night and he started crying so I
just go smoke with that full in the
backyard and then you didn't even give a
[__] they were in the backyard
somebody pulled up I know but he was
crying before that too and he was he was
you know He barked at the fools that
pulled up yeah yeah but that was a weird
that was a weird Aura on that truck yeah
he felt the bad energy
but the thing is before he even barked
me and you were staring at that truck
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah I was
like oh [__] with this [__] truck
[__] weird Vibes with some [__]
because yeah it was something like that
yeah at all
because we were a big conversation we
both looked and I noticed you weren't
talking anymore and I looked and you
were looking too I was like oh yeah okay
something's yeah what the [__] was that
then we talked about I think he's the
neighbor like no no it's not hey by the
way how do you not know your neighbor's
truck
oh yeah that's the neighbor oh no
because they have a red truck too so we
sit in the trail like oh [__] oh okay I
caught a good glitch that go wait a
minute gigantic ass lifted that's not it
you know I would have thought his name
would be Raider well that's what I did I
think because the Raiders I did I
couldn't even write it gotcha
it's like he didn't want to be so
spot-on but kind of like yeah
you know
writer's my son's middle name oh [__]
wait Cam's middle name the writer right
here with a y
EP
that's gangster right stop
fighter yeah
I never thought about that wait this is
not on purpose no shut the [__] up no I
just thought it was a cool ass name I
literally never thought about it your
favorite human is
your son
middle name Ryder did she bring up that
it was DMX ever
that's sexual camera I literally never
thought of that really what you did yeah
that was just a subconscious thing
I was gonna name Ariana that if she was
a boy why [__] six years later we
bring the name back for him yeah you
were gonna name him writer his first
name no no if like Ariana was a boy she
was gonna be Camden Rider just out of
nowhere we just made the name up oh my
God wait are there what's your other
daughter's middle name Rose Ariana Rose
oh that's fine I'm already learned oh
that's normal this was over here kind of
[__] when he goes to get called out
for games now Jesus Christ bro what did
she do to him he said he looks like the
uh he what was it he looks like the
richest kid from The Little Rascals when
he's in the pool with a slick hair
mess with Darla that's what cam looks
like except he's like I'll Juke the [__]
you put you in a arm bar too
you got a wild ass Rider ass kid I can't
believe his middle name is writer
that's dope that's dope that's like a
rapper name it's like Kimbo Slice
would you do this on purpose
yo I don't believe that he didn't think
a little bit of DMX it had to be in
there somewhere yeah it had to be yeah a
little bit come on I'm gonna actually
name my son Thomas at this Billy Madison
like oh I never even thought about it
yeah
that'd be cool my roomba's name hey
[__] so I won't say that it'll
turn on that's [__] awesome oh no the
mop the mop his name is hey [__]
pretty cool technology
you're lighting that cool
dope in that blue flame
he does not get wait he didn't even
finish his joint which one the one
that's not finished well I'm not gonna
finish that one but taste this one then
I'm gonna rope another one
in the edit please go to this joint yeah
for sure that is half of a joint that's
a tiny rope you're not going to want to
smoke it anymore why yeah smoke it after
me oh that's what I was
at first you said I put it out
I wanted to take this one since you know
we're all switching joints
it's so fresh look it's so sticky that
this is how long it burns bro I mean you
could live I've been smoking this [__]
since we started that shit's burning
slow it's because you didn't smoke it so
much I'm gonna switch it up to uh mijo's
weed right here that's fresh off the
stock out of dtvg shout out to [__]
BTS yeah first weed sponsor ever last
week along with uh I got tagged in hella
posted people down there yeah for sure
if you're ever there ask for OG
specifically and say I want him to serve
me the weed all day do it to him all day
guys
I personally get him to eyeball me and
eight that's already packaged and win
he's so legendary
that's the promo code you gotta use okay
OG do it for me and also can you clean
the bathrooms too
look at him underneath this he's
staring at me under those [__] loaks
now question for you guys in the news
raw apparently won a big lawsuit I
didn't
read it
I didn't read it
you beat the case right he's good no
just happened like yesterday oh what
something else another one another thing
I said Rob beats OCB and like is it a
defamation case or what is it raw
Rolling Papers wins 1.5 million in
copyright in front copyright
infringement there you go oh [__] but
what did they copy oh the package
against OCB yep against OCB damn so he
turned around and sued them for some
[__] yo did we talk we didn't talk about
this on the podcast I think we did the
first the first part of the OCB lawsuit
was it was me remember oh yeah and we
talked about that because OG and me and
him been doing raw [__] just as long as
each other you know I'm saying like he
knows Josh when he smoke out and [__]
and uh
the first part of the OCB lawsuit was
unfair business practices and promotions
and
I talked about it but Josh told me I can
legally talk yeah Josh told me like bro
this is like five years there's pictures
of you on a board in court in the
courtroom they're showing look at this
guy then showing all your following like
look at that it's he's their Master this
is unfair business promotions he does
weed they're actually showing that these
are for we that's not promotion she
can't promote that
you can't promote Rolling Papers it's
more weird you just can't promote
Rolling Papers except for like banners
maybe socials but you can't like get a
like a what is it you can't do magazine
what is it uh no I think it's uh because
we is the same thing right yeah same
[__] you can't put weed and you just
kind of what we're doing exactly what
we're doing this is the only promotions
you can't really get on TV you can't I
can't remember what Josh told me he
explained it to me but then again it was
a long time ago maybe like how you can't
drink alcohol in a commercial type of
shot maybe that's because you can only
hold some [__] like that and then hard
liquor whenever whenever we would have
to roll up [__] we have to roll up with
like some fake [__] grass I have
never done that in my [__] life I
never will but Josh did have material
yeah those material you would call it
material and it was fake weed so he
didn't get flagged I'd rather get
flagged but
he doesn't get in trouble that way and
that's [__] awesome for him
he's that's his company he needs it to
work like he needs to show [__] that's
not my company I'm like yeah I'm Gonna
Roll weed yeah I'll get in trouble and
get in trouble yeah [__] that [__] yeah
um because what if I actually smoke it
and forget which one I rolled up like oh
I just put some [__]
plastic whatever the [__] that [__] is I
don't think they actually smoke it
or do they they really smoke it the
material [__]
uh no I don't well you know what maybe
they do he is a material girl I wouldn't
doubt it living in a material world
you I [__] with that [__] they would
they were sensitive but you know I'll
just put weed in there bro PCP is very
explosive
for sure I remember when they were
[__] with Rob bro
yep for sure
what did he say you were staring at me
as I said it to you no I didn't smoke
that [__] I mean I believe people did
smoke it but I didn't
but you talk about the fake we do that
all I did was quote blood and blood out
look at you yeah
what did he say what the [__] is
happening we're talking about the
[__] that fake grassy [__]
he jumped into a whole different movie
scene
yep that's my brain was over here
looking down at us going say something
to break that up and I said that the
lady yeah I'm gonna break that one up
yeah
it's good huh that's interesting though
it seems like Josh kind of [__] he
did the Colin Kaepernick to all those
[__] charges and kind of came out of
time yeah yeah I did I did the story
time about it and uh yeah that first
part of lawsuit was all about that [__]
and that's why we're all stopped
couldn't really promote or post me or
anything for a long time
anyway I don't even think they sent
anybody anything anymore right sure yeah
we don't even like no no boxes or
anything anymore I think like because
they're in the lawsuit right now I think
I have no clue
yeah well we got to get them back on
here and figure this [__] out that'd be
[__] cool yo um I get a lot of DMS
about OG's last episode or the two
episodes ago when you kept stealing your
neighbor's Honda to sell weed and I get
a lot what'd he say when you come
stealing your neighbor's Honda
repetitively over a long course of time
borrowing it without them knowing
pretty crazy and then they found out
suspected no they I think they knew I
think they were just getting scared that
they didn't want to [__] tell me
anything I think so it had to be because
I drove by them and they were out there
you know
just all of a sudden they must have went
to their back door and I pulled in and I
walked out and then the dude went back
and he seen it and he was just kind of
like looking around like saying [__] you
know like you know I'm not crazy but he
and he might have a clue I think he had
a clue but I think maybe just said you
know what [__] it just not gonna say
nothing I mean they're just [__] um
shot a dude like about two weeks before
that a week before that I shot dude and
uh [__] I went back there to see you
like who got shot and like just looked
over my balcony from the top bottom
there was a dude right there with his
leg dangling and he's like oh man he was
hitting their door you know like [__]
hoping help me help me and they're like
[__] that they didn't open the door for
him and I'm outside the dude just shut
up already bro they're coming for you
already you know dude just shut up
already yeah because because he kept
[__] saying oh they're kind of go bro
no one's coming for you bro the dude's
long gone already imagine you're shot
you got OG above you shut up dick
just my kids asleep well not bro I mean
he did [__] made me drop from my
[__] from my couch to the floor you
know what I mean even though I didn't
realize that all of a sudden I was
living on top I'm way higher than what
it is I just hit my head I thought I was
[__] yeah or some [__] so I was like
[__] we throw ourselves to the floor
still from the couch you know what I
mean you know it was like [__] what am I
doing then I hear a dude yelling
screaming and go to the back look down
my balcony he's right there screaming so
at first I understand all right bro
you're I see your leg [__] high
falling off falling off it was like
dangling
no 357. oh like above his knee or maybe
right hit him right like in the middle
like in the bone in the middle just
[__] made his dick like boom
oh and he was right down the floor and
he was hitting their door hitting there
doing people weren't opening because
they're scared you know I mean come on
of course
I did kind of shut him up and then the
people came out to their front doors it
was like oh [__] so you know I was like
nah don't worry about it you know this
guy's just then the cops came in just
[__] it's crazy how long until they
got there oh they were there [__]
about maybe I think it took about oh not
like 20 minutes because [__] they got
to secure the area too yeah the
ambulance won't pull in if it's a
shooting because they don't want to get
shot neither they don't know if there's
an act you know dude someone still
shooting you know so they'll [__]
they'll stick around the area but they
won't go in until the cops all right
yeah come in but the cops will come in
first before the ambulance do when it
comes like to a shooting like that have
to do with gangs or something like that
they will not are they super like if
there's a shooting nobody gets hit but
some shots go off are the cops locking
down the whole neighborhood yeah they do
is they'll pull up and they'll [__]
they'll tape it up and they'll start
picking up the shells
just to see like a [__] so just to
say like so they're honest my real
question was the shooter has been around
doing the same shooting the cops in East
L.A they're super intense all up in your
life or are they barely in the equation
and they hardly show up type of [__]
right now I mean I don't know let me
[__] because I'm I'm not really I don't
I don't I don't [__] around no more [__]
so I don't really but I just see like
they're still probably about the same
bro they're right there looking around
but they don't [__] with me I mean I
don't you know I don't really see too
much I see it but not not for me like
before like when I was younger yeah it
was like damn bro I'll be getting pulled
over every damn [__] every [__]
guaranteed every week twice a week
getting pulled over do you ever get
pulled over in the neighbor Civic
I almost did bro I'm not gonna lie there
was a chance where there was a time
where I almost [__] came very very
close but [__] and just dip out like
I said I would always put on like a
different type of hat like a white
little tight it had like a tennis hat or
some [__] I'll put on something
stupid bro just to [__] just to get
by bro I had problems in the bag I was
like [__] they did I I ran into one
like you know head to head but it looked
like they're gonna point out like [__]
I'm about to get this to get off this
[__] start running but didn't happen
right so they just stayed behind you and
didn't I had cops come behind me I guess
they'll run the plates and you know it's
so intense in those moments like oh [__]
yeah bro especially if you're in a
[__] stolen car well I don't know the
thing is that I I kind of knew it would
have been reported stolen but then there
was that little chance like what if
these people got up and said where's my
[__] car yeah of course I was like
dude you know it's impossible but [__]
it it's a chance impossible well because
I would think for these people are not
gonna get up at [__]
11 o'clock 12 O'Clock they're gonna be
out already they wake up [__] the
next morning at 5 30 in the morning to
go to work program you know I mean they
were just like every day so what we're
saying is
OG not only we thought man just got shot
you wasted three [__] aprons on this
guy can you believe this weather toughen
him up Good Fellas over here don't give
a [__] next time this kid gets a [__]
letter one more letter head first in the
[__] oven you're gonna go yeah
dude shut up already bro cause you're
screaming at me like a [__] shoot
stop bro shut the [__] up stop being
dramatic oh your legs off shut the [__]
up
yo the the fact the whole time I was
thinking Danny got shot you're being a
dick and then he says no his leg was
hanging off set your Private Ryan [__]
going the full guy hit in D-Day style
and this was like shut the [__] up
they're not coming back [__]
I mean unless I call him if you don't
shut the [__] up why don't you say you I
got a gun I'll cover you I've seen
people get shot bro [__]
I've seen people as one time off the
first they do get shot in his face right
right here bro on the freeway dude was
just dude just got off and he was just
like [__] you know what I mean he's
alive yeah
we're right behind him and also I just
this was [__] I think I was like 16
years old you're driving no no I was I
was in my and one in a friend's car I
actually I was still young I was like
about 16 years old okay
and [__] we pull up we're getting off
the free ride it was actually off the
exit might say it might have been
Central one of those streets out there
in downtown L.A we pull it right behind
him and just you just hear Pam bam so
you pull behind the guy and somebody
comes beside him yeah another car comes
beside him the one we're in back of
shoot him bam dude gets off the car like
nothing and he has a [__] hole right
there in his [__] head right right in
between your [__] nose and right you
know right here bam when solid oh bro
and he gets off the car and he's just
like like nothing like [__] like I'll
just worry like damn like he says I feel
like like like he said he felt like some
[__] like his face was compressed but
he was still [__] like nothing bro
and I was like damn fool like [__] it I
was the guy he was still young about 30
years old maybe oh [__] you know he was
young and yeah bro dude like nothing
survived that was one you know I've seen
I've seen another one of my boys got
shot in [__]
[__] forehead right he ran between
the eyes literally the bullet came out
to the top so the bully 22 again yeah it
was a 22. yo those are weird it's like
shooting under water oh yeah that should
[__] travel the fact that you could
only have a head shot is wild with a 22.
oh yeah right in between his two eyes
bro it went in and came out of this
[__] forehead he had a he had a bump
on his phone he had a [__] hole
through his in between his eyes right
here going [__] up did he just figure
the [__] out of him huh did he look all
crazy now nah nothing what stop oh [__]
what a little [__] scar that looks
like oh it did like chunk his head off
oh no bro just went right in and came
right out he had a hole right here
no he was he was literally inside the
fat oh [__] I literally had told him
go inside the pet food you know it's hot
out here right now they didn't listen to
me and I went inside and as soon as I
closed my front door and your [__]
gunshots came back out and get up there
like [__] they shot this fool where is
he oh he's in the restroom looking
himself in the mirror and he was in the
mirror look he's like oh [__] yeah take
a shot [__] damn we're like that fool
will sit down before he's like ah these
two is like nothing was he on one no
it's just probably maybe maybe just beer
anything oh wow we're drinking so what
do you go to the hospital
you really put that perspective as wild
also 22s don't do [__] yeah for sure
twenties are dangerous man they're
dangerous but there's no [__]
hit you right here bro and that [__]
could through your heart forget it kill
you I get that but if you're shooting at
someone's heart with a 22 it's better to
hit him in the chat in the in the
[__] left side the 22 it's very
dangerous good it's like they just do
Wiggles it's so weird they [__] you up
though it's like a pinball yeah you get
yourself [__] in the arms come out
your neck that's you know what that is
scary actually yeah take that back 22's
you're [__] scary
mm-hmm when I was [__] 12 we stole a
[__] 357 Magnum out of the kids out
of a random person's house
you guys went in Friday Style
yeah yeah yeah one of our boys [__]
to think about it now being 12 like 11
12 years old and like my boys just
scoping out houses and [__] like yeah no
they're not even I think they're left
and then by thinking about my kids now
doing that [__] is [__] insane just
going through going in people's houses
what happened you guys just said you
know that house is empty let's go yeah
we went in there that [__] couple
times we were terrorizing this goddamn
neighborhood but this one house it was
with [__] Goofy and Goofy came out
with a [__] purse
we went back into the [__] woods and
[__] after came out with this big ass
purse unzip that [__] big ass [__]
gun a little Dirty Harry
I think it was uh 44 may I don't know
guns all like that in my mind it was
like from GoldenEye 3577 yeah it was
pretty long days it was a big ass
[__] gun in this big ass
I don't know what it was but that [__]
lived in my [__] closet for a long
ass time until the whole neighborhood
the neighborhood congregated on us
meaning like they like had a big ass
meeting like yeah
put it under us terrorizing it yeah
you had to move goofy moved and why
because they said you're [__] up the
neighborhood it was really bad it was
really [__] bad to the point that
they knew we were the only this is a
small little neighborhood we're the only
it was real obvious what the [__] was
going on wait you're two white kids
right yeah
this was a regular neighborhood too by
the way
oh [__] it was like four or five of us
this was a regular neighborhood this
isn't in Lackawanna like they weren't
almost well you're out in the ghetto
still no this was when I lived in like
ski country oh [__]
the two white kids were terrorized in
the ghetto so bad that they kicked them
out when I really started hanging out
like in the hood and [__] I already had
already gone through that whole phase of
doing all this extra [__] it was almost
out of my system
which was good because it would have
been a lot [__] Dumber
but the thing is I think about the
stupid [__] we did just Reckless stupid
[__] like that and uh
it got even way Dumber
how unnecessary it was just how dumb you
are as a kid so how many houses did you
guys go into
in your stretch of a criminal it was
probably six they are honestly the first
time scary second time I know we're
definitely getting caught this one third
[Music]
you're pushing it and you wouldn't say
we were like that was just the tip of
the spear though we were [__]
terrorizing the entire neighborhood
though yeah we used to take your socks
off and put them on your hands
oh
[Laughter]
you don't need no friends
I just thought he meant in general so
yeah we were terrorizing hey you guys
ever take a socks off put them on your
hands
I didn't know you better break into a
place you know what I mean you ever
heard of gloves no but [__] hey when it
happens it goes down it goes down right
so you don't think about that okay take
your socks off yeah take your socks out
put them on and [__] you know that
way you need no Prince
rear brake and [__] we were not thinking
about anything but just being [__]
real dumb in the moment yeah
I've never done that I had the smartest
kid in our school another separate gun
incident
smartest kid in my high school by far
like valedictorian [__] this kid was
pulled out of his mind
blowing pills during class all that type
of [__] on the desk
but me and him were friends he was on
the basketball team and shut
and like I had gotten into this
situation where I needed a [__] gun
he gets me warm we meet this kid in this
back of the store we get this fun gun
now I got my uncle's truck I'm my uncle
used to let me house set so I'm like
house sitting at this moment and I have
his truck
he gets in the car he's like we got this
[__] two cup holders full of bullets
and [__] he's like looking at it and
[__] does it to the ground of the car
like checking if there's a [__]
bullet in it like nope all clear
but would have shot through the [__]
floor of the car
I remember thinking like oh my
smartest kid I know I'm the smartest kid
I know will shut his foot off yeah I'm
gonna Bloom [__] my boy's [__]
head off
yeah how did this happen wait [__] in
the garage yeah in the garage or in the
garage [__] we had got this [__]
uh I've got this like 25 years ago yeah
I got this [__] Hungarian gun [__]
[__] testing it up [__] licking oh
[__] this one has a safety oh [__] look
you put one on top and look it's like
it's you got one on top and you can put
the safety in like nothing nothing goes
off and then they take it off and then
all of a sudden bam
telling them all about it like oh we
[__] turns he moves it and [__] up
I was like [__] I thought I did hit him
and ah [__] amen
yeah he does right oh my God I had a
poster on the wall a [__] of uh I
think you lost it La Jolla and a [__]
shot right now
[Music]
you ever see the video of that cop in
the school demonstrating
saw that one all right this is okay this
is okay
because buff dude with the dreads
now this is okay
the the the the cop instructor he has
the gun it [__] shoots off
he doesn't say anything goes down
purpose he goes oh yeah that's the one
that was on that that was on purpose yes
that was wild it was that was yes it was
nah nipples shot almost killed somebody
or you guys see that or [__] Flag but
you guys ever see the one with the
instructor everything they always blur
it out the full dies we're they're at
the range yeah go with the kid
the little girl she's like six
six-year-old little blonde girl or brown
hair girl she has an Uzi and the
instructors with her
right and she's like this and he's
talking to everybody all right so this
is how we're gonna do this see how she's
small blah blah and she has and it goes
off
and it goes like this and this fool just
I was just talking
so sad sad it shot backwards because
it's she's a girl
he died yeah oh really which one was
that one which I just explain this wait
wait because I remember when exactly
like that but I just shot the dude's
head off I mean his hat off oh his hat
off no no he had a hat on bro you shot
up I've seen that one yeah
[Laughter]
it's really sad the videos at the I
thought you were talking about the gun
range videos I've seen those don't seen
those imagine being that the guy that
has to stand behind everybody and like I
mean what are you really supposed to do
the the dude's just shooting at the gun
range like normal and then
like and the dude even again that was
that a gun range yeah yeah I think
because he was using probably different
uh different types he did it on purpose
purpose oh he did yeah but there was a
dude standing right behind him like I'm
apparently I've gone I've never been to
a gun range apparently I would imagine
there was a guy there ready to tackle
you if you start shooting people there's
never anybody with you oh the race are
scary bro there's a bunch of people that
I don't know their state of mind with
guns
gun ranges are scary yeah I rather go to
the woods of their homies hmm
I go to I did somewhere in La the LA Gun
Club he goes right there in the back of
a 7-Eleven
it's the first mission it's the one
where the guy gets pissed and he smokes
in it so he's like I won't smoke in your
store anymore and he just shoots the
back of his building all day that's good
to go bro you know yeah
yeah I'm trying it's good to go so that
way you should think about it you just
never said well do these guys
yeah yeah
you got one also Mark I got I didn't I
think yeah Mario's got some [__] the one
the shotgun I got was [__] fun though
you already shot it no I need to go get
tactically trained with that monster of
a gun
remember that one yeah
I need to be safe that's sick and the
pistols and [__] that's all I know to
use all that [__] it's just I need to
get like John Wick tactical so I don't
hurt anybody
no bro I need to learn how to clean my
[__] open this gun up do all take it
apart know how to load it know how to do
my [__] that way I'm like
get out of here
you don't want it you know what I mean
yeah if they need to go all right I'm
gonna shoot you the knee yeah yeah don't
push it but uh will take him his leg off
though like here homie and so I'm gonna
do the same thing
and I'm like yo shut up well they're not
even here anymore shut up your leg's
hanging off that's how I'm gonna do
here I don't know what it was dude it
was just [__] just you know Annoying
you yeah he was bro he was yelling too
much he was yelling too much his leg
came off
still bro still bro that's craziest
thing I've ever heard you say I mean
look at him because you've seen other
fools get shot with shotguns
did you be like yo bro
dramatic ass [__] it's just a shotgun
you didn't [__] you're not dead yeah
yeah but they're dead they couldn't yell
well look at it wow I just go look at it
when you get hit there you get your
endorphins of heroin or [__] uh
whatever you want to call it the uh what
is it called
[Laughter]
let me tweak yourself
what is it called no it's a [__] um
the painkillers [__] are we carrying
our body oh Excedrin yeah there you go
you hear me as soon as that kicks in bro
he's gonna go away I believe damn
oh my God
it's your joint keep
it up why do you always call me Simon
Simon because that's your middle name
you know no it's not
what's your middle name
don't have it you don't have one
just mysterious guys I don't know if you
can see this
um I want to wait for Marty to put that
back on so we can get a better angle of
it
um
what's your middle name
don't have a meal I told you you know
what
oh there we go
I don't I don't have a better name I
don't believe you you have a pinky ring
remember you lost it we talked about the
last night this full lost this pinky
reefers so long
and never told anybody
for about a month and a half too it's
like Superman losing his cave yeah he's
so embarrassed he never told anybody and
then somebody else found it dude I think
I just had a gardener like maybe about a
month or no I had gotten about two
months but the mic or I had gotten about
two months ago so [__] is this is
everybody I wore a Pro Club to calm my
son down so he felt more at ease so if
you're wondering why I'm wearing this
Pro Club [__] it's because he's a little
kid you know when you dress up as
Superman for your kids
this is he's like yo please please
please please
damn he was waiting a thermal yeah
it's for you [__] the back says no fear
with a dog thermal sick what's your
what's your pants I want a card meal I
see with your pants
yo you guys start oh that's what I said
earlier remember we're on live remember
when I was a kid you're like please
please please let me get Cortez's let me
get Cortez's and I was like no you can't
get Cortez you can't rock Cortez's
they're gonna think you're a gangster
you're like no let me get cortezism I
have three flowers and like everything's
gonna be so sick and I'm gonna look sick
I'm a netted hair thing remember
I'm like you're gonna look like a
cafeteria lady OG you know look at this
you work at a cafeteria like no no I'll
be serving fools like all right remember
oh yeah bro those are the days we're
gonna be serving food like yeah that's
why you need the hair net huh [__]
remember increase your pass out
remember I used to rock the I used to
rock the uh wife beaters and you're like
let me get away and then I gave you one
remember I was like yo little nugget
it's always still my [__] muscle
shirts all the time I used to rub his
little head like come on get out there I
gotta actually I have a few videos
yeah it was cool I'm cool with that
joint too you're whack you know man
there's none of your joints what do you
mean she's not even finished no because
bro I'm not gonna say I smoke a whole
joint
no I'm gonna smoke you have like three
different four different flavors for me
food Marty points
don't worry and you can't say no to it
four lines of cocaine
for the Drake liquor straight wears no
headphones two hours late I'm kicking my
feet
because he's because he had to give him
the Cortez's and he's like [__] your
shoes that's what's going on man huh we
got your little jeezies yeah they're
called jeezies what are they called
Jesus
as Mr jeezies that's what they're called
here
yo we had a topic and I forgot it
I had one and I was going to ask we were
talking about guns when I first stood up
uh that's true that's true oh the gun
range yeah yeah yeah okay got a gun but
also to use it you ready as officially
as of last night you have no more kids
in school nope that's it done imagine an
air horn going around
imagine the air horn going off we can
hear it we're celebrating you officially
have no more children in the school nope
done all of them before graduated wow
that's goddamn amazing
I'm [__] 15 years off that oh I reset
that clock boy I would have been out
four years from now
uh 15 years then
oh got it oh yeah no more like 12. okay
I was just doing the math like yeah
loose math loose rough math loose man 15
years oh yeah where your kids are well
right now my youngest one's five so oh
yeah you're still good well you gotta
enjoy it because that shouldn't go by so
fast what I'm really scared of is my
oldest daughter started to drive and
being around kids that are driving oh
yeah that's that's scary it's [__]
horrifying it is it is how did you deal
with that what was the rules I'm still
going through it
even with my with my oldest the 25 year
old she still go with it I still go
through that [__] really you know I
still gotta be right there I think
it it just yeah it gets a little more
stressful because you know another
little teen adults and you know now you
gotta like just 20 [__] now you gotta
watch [__] you know yeah their
friends that drink and have a car you
know what I mean they think they can
drive you're like [__] yeah that's right
um for the formulas not um they're
pretty I'm pretty on it bro I'm always
freaking letting them know what time it
is it's like it's 12.
I'm [__] high yeah one time you
rolled OG joints you're like yo you guys
can't have any of them yeah yeah I got
one right here guys remember that [__]
it was sick do you need a joint yeah I
need one you want to smoke a little one
it's a jack joint yeah let me try the
Jack fool for sure would you say this
weed that we have here is the frostiest
craziest here ticket looking nuggets
you've ever seen little [__] jerk
gotta be up there right the the OG the
true OG that OG roll was some of the
best weed ever so or a g group that's
just it's real fresh it hasn't been
ripped yeah you know I mean my son might
complain like oh he's gonna complain it
was very early
and earthy last night
when we're at your house
oh you tried it then yeah oh okay so
then you'll like it then the same one I
said last night
[Music]
hold on you're comparing so you're
comparing this current OG oh you did
that gotcha okay Marty said hey the Wii
we rolled up earlier that one right
there OG that was some of the cake most
caked perfect looking weed I've seen in
a while right a joint
this party yes and this is a jack right
it tastes like a Jack from cbx I don't
know okay oh okay Savino but
[Music]
the perfect nogs the weed was so caked
right and he said yo is that some of the
most cakes we've ever seen I said no the
true OG that OG grew was some of the
best food I've ever seen and then you
went like this fell off
to the BAM I don't like plants no no he
used to be all about the plants oh it
was actually my nephew did some [__]
and got me the whole block card you can
grow one plant oh no bro it was worse
you know say right now you can grow one
place oh right now now for sure I've
been working on it now I am that's all
I'm oh now I'm doing my interesting
regular rooms what I could do so it came
to an abrupt end
like it was going so good where like I
was like yes [__] finally I got my
butt I can grow and I'm growing my own
[__] and
bam after that I got into some [__] not
me but my nephew you know lived on the
blog we did some [__] and got the
whole time block hard and next thing you
know I just had to just shut down [__]
it shut down my girl preemptively oh
yeah [__] yeah there it wasn't worth it
you know like [__] this [__] so I
[__] shut it down and uh
that's it when got me a job it got me a
job always worked but got me a job got
me another job I was like [__] I thought
I was gonna be doing good because I go
for having my little girl going on and
that only lasted for about maybe what
two years or anything no clue you kept a
day job while you're doing that uh yeah
I was still doing money today
it wasn't it was it wasn't too much it
was only a six lighter that or it was
yeah legal ass six later yeah you could
do that [__] anywhere in California
you're talking about well now but back
then it wasn't it was still it wasn't
you know it was illegal so yes it was
back then it was how many plants is that
oh [__] bro you still have six [__]
no I was like about I think I was
hitting I was doing like about
25 plants 30 plants I think maybe even I
think who knows maybe it might have been
more you know I had a good little at the
whole room filled up bro
it was it was it's like a little process
man it was making good good money off of
it and then next thing you know just bam
everything just ended so quick I just go
[__] this shut it down convert it back
into my room I think I made it to the
gym room and [__] that's it
[__] stop growing repest yeah well I
highly have bro I was pissed now I'm now
I'm gonna now I'm [__] I got some
seeds put away and [__] it's just not
hidden and I won't [__] pop up and
[__] just do something with that you
know what I mean did they last forever
I think it's been about like four years
five years and I stopped growing already
they're still good I haven't put away
any good yeah
for sure you see a lot of illegal weed
especially the weed you've seen
all the brands you see all the time you
you approve everything that goes in your
shop yeah what's the the best what's the
best legal weed you've seen in a minute
[Laughter]
well I mean we go fire [__]
stop it
you had to shoot him
a delay right that scared me [__]
shock all the way through my stomach to
my chest this little did it realization
I seen this food like oh [__] go down
on the new one yeah it has the shock
button realistic ass gunshot it scares
the [__] out of me
so you got you like that
yeah no but there's a there's a lot of
there's a lot of good streets I like
from a lot of companies bro there's not
just one and like I said we got you know
cbx secure company uh I like wolves you
know it's [__] some good [__]
oh yeah
who grows that one uh is this top shelf
top shelf yeah that's what I was saying
like top shelf it was a good one we'll
see whoa uh you know what else got so
good when uh cbx that's good [__] too
sure you know I [__] with them so do
you veto a lot of [__] out of there like
doesn't pass doesn't pass well it you
know I'm I try to be cool but you know
my thing with right now what pisses me
off a lot is that there's too much
[__] of this [__] gelato cross
[__] [__]
all this [__] cooking
are you saying like yeah all these
strings they'd be making you know
everything has two it has like [__]
gelato in it or runs and you know of
course I get everybody [__] likes
that [__] you know everybody loves that
[__] but I'm not I'm not too racism
everywhere
overall just a race I mean I just don't
I don't just I don't [__] maybe it's
just me I don't [__] with hybrids bro
I'm not a big fan of hybrids so you look
at that not that I don't [__] with them
I'm not a big fan of them okay I mean I
just like oh gee give me [__]
straight something phobic that's it all
I hear something something phobic hybrid
some crazy things yeah whatever hyper
Ford
I'm just talking [__] also I do not like
a taste of that
still fresh
of the OG it's burning amazing
The Taste it's it's it's pretty fresh uh
it's like when you when they don't cook
spinach down right and you're like oh
damn what is it gonna [__] break down
that's what that tastes like
well it's bird that to me bomb we should
mix that one with a different one
because it has a fresh ass taste where
it tastes like plant
it's Piney a little taste yeah you know
what I'm saying right right hit this one
maybe this is a different
part of the nug or something you'll see
what I'm saying it's on the side of my
tongue it's like a chewing on a stem
well that's because you know what I told
you I
still had a little lease
I didn't clean it up I didn't trim it up
right you know I just [__] rolled it
up you know damn you really tasted that
but it tastes good it's white I mean it
tastes pretty good but you want to
tasted something yeah that's what you're
tasting that's all that's the next
challenge we need is the blind taste
challenge going down dude a lot of
[__] think I'm lying toxic if
you're lying about this your must be a
[__] liar can you walk into a room OG
someone's smoking what the [__] is is
that your phone turn your phone
your phone off
[__]
what an [__] he slightly smiled when
it went off too just put it on silent
there's a little button on the side did
you click it all right there we go there
you go it's gonna go off in five minutes
anyway [__] guarantee it boss you
have a call
excuse me boss you have a text message
50 [__] times are you ready
can you walk into a room
and someone's smoking and you can know
what they're smoking just by smelling
the smoke yeah for sure like 70 of the
time yeah for sure okay unless it's like
those new crosses or some old school
[__] where I wouldn't even think like
there's no it's just not even around no
more that's definitely not [__]
Afghan but you know what I mean it's
definitely not this and you know you can
mortal you could tell if it's like a
sativa I'm not talking more about that
because you smell a hybrid right away no
you know right when you walk away
hybrids in here you can smell that [__]
right now yeah I could smell the OG
[__] right away too you know what I
mean you know that's a distinct strain
we're talking about like
the the
categories Indica hybrid Steve that's
that's different I'm talking about you
walk in and go
that's perfect punch
purple punch you can smell it not even
the weed you could smell the smoke see
people think I'm [__] talking [__]
I've done that you've seen it did it to
me all right you've seen it you've seen
it yeah but I I walk in my oh that's
this I'm like wow I haven't smelled that
in a minute I almost think I'm talking
[__] no you can do it too like when you
cookies and blue dream you're like [__]
you can smell everything distinctively
dude unless it's like this is from
something company and it's unless it's a
new it's a new process yeah and they
freaking they put their own name on it
that's what I'm saying but it has this
and then they're like oh yeah pretty
much if you're cooking like oh that's
chicken that's pork that's this that's
that like oh and you used basil but
that's how you can get we can't get down
to the well actually that's [__] uh
almond milk and [__] this coconut
like shut the [__] up
almond milk with chicken don't forget
you know what I mean like actually it's
crossed back cross for the runs you're
wrong shut up let's repurposed runs you
know so anyway we're talking [__] about
weed now
um yeah so you can't yeah yeah so we
wanna uh we wanna do a show live from a
girl room
we want to do an episode of the podcast
live from one of the rooms maybe not
live but filming oh yeah in one of the
rooms but surrounded by plants
YouTube loves when we got a YouTube girl
loves it you love it YouTube loves that
yeah what's down the line
also look
oh what happened man I don't know how to
shave no it's nice
you didn't break out knives today yeah I
mean no I didn't but this hurt it looks
like
razor wait a minute but what it's one of
the ones that do this stuff no I was
high as [__] last night and I put it
upside down and I got caught between the
thing because it was upside down and it
just went I'll kill you and then I
remember in Jim Carrey when he doesn't
catch up exactly yeah that was me last
night that's how I felt
no I was just kidding well it looks like
you [__] like you got [__] it
looks like when somebody's holding you
Ransom yeah and they just put it slowly
against your neck that's right yeah you
got really like that little cut you
little drop of little drop of blood
Burley got some blood why you keep
putting your feet all the way underneath
my feet your shoes are so cocaine white
I don't want to [__] them up no scoot
back here cause you're gonna [__] the
camera
scoot back in and I'll put my feet back
I'll put my feedback scoot back in
because the camera there you go okay go
ahead scratch your legs up all right all
right ready
I was about to say something we probably
shouldn't say that you know what getting
flagged enough it sucks and then I
thought you know that we'll just we
appreciate all the support guys and
we're back on YouTube despite you know I
mean we decided these last two episodes
are just gonna be ourselves and see what
we need restricted to death but
you guys support the episode so thank
you
say what we want hey you
what you're saying
I just can't get over that taste it's
too fresh still it's uh yeah I'm telling
you it has to be perfect I need some
water that's why I remember yesterday
when I told you you're gonna have to
take your own burp it if you wanted it
wow this product is doing well it's
crazy man huh that shadow straw
yeah sorry I just got a text message
about something really stupid
I don't want to do that no sorry
sometimes people text me with things
they're like yo he'll go for this like
that was the dumbest stuff like horrible
suggestion what kind of suggestions
yeah
what the [__] wrong with you
LG can you put on this dress it's like
Diana Ross for the skit yeah I was just
gonna do that for me right now the [__]
that's how I feel sometimes people like
would you do them like
that's right we don't hang out you don't
know me well enough
yeah no I wouldn't stop [__]
stop that [__] you should have done
better I should have no no the dude
asking you the dumb [__] oh
drop come in the end of the month end of
June we have we're dropping I think 14
items on the first drop and then three
weeks later we'll drop another 14. but
even right now to the fans we got oh
yeah we just dropped uh I'll give them
to you the uh plushie homies for Life
homies for Life plushie dice
new all-new Grinders though it'll be
sold out by the time this video comes
out for sure
eyes are pink yeah they're hot they're
high as [__] it's these guys sick these
guys right here uh-huh love these guys
made the plushies of them so sick she
always see him in a shirt another shirt
like that no no it's like a keychain I'm
like oh yeah no the key chain
I seen it you posted it up right yeah
you put you had one in your car yeah
that's just though I mean that's second
the Maybach the [__] I thought it was
an air freshener but they're like oh
[__] you know right sure this one it was
an air freshener
I just said that earlier that we need we
need the Jack Herrera push trees air
freshener oh yeah heavy bomb yo you
what's your 40.
what's your 40. what's my 440 yard dash
like what's what's your speed top speed
the NFL wide receivers got to be at
least
I'm just saying at your latest combine
yeah the latest combine yo you know what
next time you come on the show I'm gonna
be dressed just [__] like you
there you go
you look like the coach
oh the headphones yeah that's your
clipboard to block your mouth yeah
There You Go fool there you [__] go
coach
oh for oh sorry people are in the car
and [__] not even listening like what's
what's what are you talking about I just
put a piece of paper never just just
watch yeah just watch on Spotify another
giant shout out to [__] Spotify
official Partners even further like we
can't we can't shout Spotify they're
awesome guys you can follow us on
Spotify we're trying to bring all these
YouTube features to Spotify so please
support that and if they do comments on
Spotify you can thank us because that
was we're pushing that's what we're
pushing to make it a better user
experience to try to start building the
community over there more because also
makes sense don't follow OG's Instagram
you're gonna post you're gonna do [__]
he does nothing he really had you
explaining what a timeline post was
earlier yeah it was crazy huh what do
you mean [__] with them right no he
wasn't [__] me at all and I didn't
even say timeline I say post on your
main you said timeline no I did not say
timeline you said it right I don't say
timeline did you not say timeline I
don't use timeline
can we do this again
she joins look at all the joints his man
didn't finish yet bro I had to try out
the same time flavors smoke all the same
time yeah come on I don't know come on
no come on
I'm pretty sure you got another
different flavor back there what you got
all the same flavors
I could be wrong I don't know uh yeah it
might be scared [__]
this one's too short
I can't believe you're out here wasting
weed this is crazy bro I had to try all
of them you used to be a smoker is he uh
like a triple blinker pen type of dude
no see him dude
nothing triple whip he don't take the
shots he don't think nothing was it two
liquid diamonds in the oh [__]
yeah OG used to be really cool with the
weed and he was like oh I can't do it no
more
oh very easy to take gloves Mindy he
used to take
a lot and now he's like no
do you remember Mrs Doubtfire when he's
redoing this he's doing Robin Williams
is doing the bird voiceover he's like no
don't smoke
that this [__] now my lungs
check it out you know you know you know
what you know what it was why I used to
take [__] big ass dabs like that and
[__] bro I was [__] Zanny the [__]
out bro so you need drugs to be down bro
what are you trying to say huh take glad
[__] whip two grams three grams not
true not true no [__] lie say you
take three grams yet
I like that you said that so I brought
this out just for you and look as he
said
the regret underneath the looks is the
best part
take that
I can't take the absence
I was mid-joints and threw him down
that's how excited I am do you got a
diaberg at home or a Carter or something
nope I got one still I just got to put
away I don't feel like [__] so you'd
never dab I do not too much though as
much like that Mindy what's the last
time you dabbed at home
oh she went
oh
we're depriving this whole family and
[__]
like no I can't handle it you guys all
can't take dabs it's like Footloose is
for dabbing nah I can take that guy
you've been on the Edibles heavy though
right uh Edibles yeah I've been [__]
loud with Edibles because I was editing
the videos right here he just looks so
are you okay it's smoky in here I'm
sorry my bad I forgot
I [__] just slickled in I didn't see
him I forgot right because I keep
looking over here and the camera's
blocking him with the smoke down here my
bad my bad we just [__] passed it's
crazy
back there
with the pants
I think it Blends in
oh he's saying the desk behind you
Blends in with your pants I like that
that's what you told him so I'm looking
like this bro I can't even like see him
there oh because his pants disappeared
no that's cool [__] the [__] like
this [__] up boom all right Marty this
is cool ask him some [__] what you got
right there yeah we got here animal face
from oh the animal face but the black
can't smell this one smell as well smell
this one all right all right for
everybody at home this is just hash out
this is some hash
this is prop hash yeah the prop hash
smells like Black Death it's called
black cam
it smells like rancid old food that like
sat out and then got hot let me see
it does
look
right yeah it kind of does it's crazy
that you're about to dab a half gram of
that it smells so slow
it's crazy he's about to do this
I'm excited all right Marty sorry take
it away take it away I have to have to
go over here to get away from them is
this the same one my bad guys we're over
here doing [__] that's not podcast you
can't you can't hear any of it and this
is a torch don't think your [__] tire
is blowing out
so you got the uh what's the name of
that the Banger you put on there now I
don't know is that the one that it goes
up with it yes hmm
it is it's called a I think it's called
a control tower
could be wrong oh gee yeah remember you
don't post anything anymore what do you
do now
um you know how you don't do pictures
yourself anymore what do you do now like
you just sit at the office and
do what
it's working on a few things full of
organized beatboxing career in his head
though so he's not actually practicing
he's just thinking about the Beats no
I'm working on some [__] man there's
some [__] coming in when's the last time
you did some break dancing oh that was
the last time
I break dance
don't shut every day
[__] around I [__] around you hit us
hits on the floor real quick
that's what you need on that main feed
yo take dog faces spot and start dancing
even harder and then at the end you rip
a joint and be like yo this feels way
harder dick
I don't know it did sound kind of weird
but you got you you like it it's worth
it
oh camera camera camera camera camera
hey you know you keep turning there you
go so you put the block the whole camera
Rosie
that
podcasts will be overview maybe I'll
always explaining how you say made me
feel all ugly broccoli was like what
does that mean OG says when he doesn't
like things it makes him feel gross that
it makes him feel ugly the treatment me
feel ugly inside so I don't want to make
you feel ugly inside with this [__]
because I know you're a [__] quit the
podcast it's a little dab yeah all right
you got the matching marble a little
marbles is from our store the
reupstore.com
this nail is sick as [__] and you know
what's crazy you can't cheat this thing
will Spin and lift when you actually hit
it so you gotta actually hit it because
you're a cheater you don't like to
actually take home careful don't break
my [__] I got you no no lead tour you're
notorious for breaking my [__] I got you
just breathe just breathe don't touch
anything
yeah break my [__] [__] my car up look
at him stall it's what's cold go you got
this
damn that's cool
not that hard not the heart
because you don't want that that to get
over this
so I keep it right there you know what
I'm saying
that's crazy
well thank you so much for joining this
episode podcast
[Laughter]
this [__] look at his face I know when
OG wants to be like damn flashlight we
feel anxious
I can see it on his face already you got
any water or anything bro
got some shots over here because I'll
talk to you in about five minutes Marty
what you've been up to man how's your
back what are you saying yeah that's
great
the backyard is [__] great thank you
guys making that [__] happen oh yeah you
were saying uh we were talking about the
Grinders and the backpacks and the
plushies and everything coming out but
shortly
in the near future we got 16 new items
coming from push trees was it 24. 24
excuse me 20. what's that gonna include
20. we got hella shirts pants uh swim
bikini shorts skateboards trying to make
pool floaties sweaters thank you
Chenille patches on a lot of the clothes
we have all uh like uh
like the letters that are cut out and
put on sweaters
like when they're when they're when
they're sewn on patches kind of but not
like Letterman Patches from school I'm
probably explaining it bad but yeah
that's why it is yeah you are okay
okay so we have all that [__] coming out
we have new all our shout out to
Burberry for the inspiration hmm but I
kind of looked at Burberry I was like yo
that's a nice tag
hey man just to say like I like the way
the tag is shaped I like the shape what
is it it's a canvas tag uh canvas neck
tags now that are going to be sewn in
like the designer Brands that's cool and
also we're gonna do a thing called like
the green line in our heads but the
green line means we spent dumb ass
amount of money making this
I hope people really [__] with it
because it's expensive yeah uh and all
those have rubber tags sewn in but like
see-through rubber stamps so would that
green line be like jackets or like
specialty cool that's exactly what that
is it's gonna be uh jackets pants shorts
sweaters with crazy patches
yeah I'm excited how would you describe
like the graphics on all these new
shirts or just the look of this very
clean
very clean and simple Pro Club
Pro Club inspired
I'm just kidding I'm just looking at OG
to make him get involved
[Laughter]
the last drop was nice with a nice green
tie-dye and just bringing it back in
ship but this time this this drop that's
coming was correct me if I'm wrong like
being designed even before you dropped
the last drop right yeah yeah we've been
we're a real company now yeah yeah so
it's pretty sick it's pretty Tad yeah
I'd love to see that it's getting like
the attention it deserves and they're
going out and getting great photos yeah
I'm excited dude so when does this come
on now this one in a month oh sure end
of the month oh gee when are you gonna
[__] make your Wii company or
something
I got I got some [__] coming up oh okay
cool
all right Fool's always ask me I've
heard Rumblings
is there still Rumblings going on or not
what does that mean
I'm very lost in your vocabulary I'm
hearing rumbling rumbling is that OG
style oh you're saying like
conversations yeah yeah sorry I don't
think I've ever I've never heard that
one I might have made that out you know
what I don't think you did I don't think
you did I think you read the dictionary
one day I guess I mean you stored it
away okay sorry streets are talking the
streets are talking
how you feeling how you feeling with
that Dad now I feel it remember you told
that girl it was like some um black Kim
sativa kinda no it breaks the team I
don't know I don't know remember when
you told that guy to shut up his light
got blown off that was crazy I keep
thinking about it actually yeah it's a
sativa it is a sativa that's just
[__] you scared now you have a panic
attack no I just I could feel it more up
here than my like my body
that's good my bad I guess actually it
was perfect we were [__] wrecked last
episode we do we have any sort of count
on like oh no idea
somebody in this episode let us know how
much [__] did we smoke on the goat part
two let us know God damn you got the
matching torch
looking like kill a camera think about
that I gotta be honest didn't even think
about that
you got the match you said so I have
different ones
um oh gee
back to you complaining about guy
yelling so what happened to the guy the
ambulance came and his leg was falling
off
yeah so this [__] leg was [__]
dangling [__] dude got [__] Amber
just came for his ass
actually the cops first came and they
asked them hey
yeah oh was this in the 90s or more
recently yeah
this was actually like in uh 2002 maybe
oh okay you know what I mean and um
yeah the cops came and they asked them
when
a matter of fact dude started snitching
started saying who did it oh and I'm
upstairs I'm watching that sun I'm
hearing everything
yeah a matter of fact uh the cop even
told me to go inside because I was
[__] talking [__] you know I was like
you know throwing little suggestions
like little comments like what
I was just like [__] I was just like
[__] you know what I mean I want to
hear one thing you said what did you say
to him I think I told her [__] um
I'm gonna give you a slice of cheese oh
you were saying because you were
snitching [__] yeah gotcha because he
was tying the cops you know who did it
who shot it oh yeah this car and he
lives there he lives there and I'll just
like hmm you know like [__] and I knew I
didn't know who he was but I just know
that he was you know someone hanging
around there and he was supposedly he
was a gang member and then what are you
doing Jesus Christ so what are you doing
you know you had a civil war wound why
are you snitching
shut up
I like it it's [__] ruthless so have
you been back to the casino that you've
been kicked out of yet
uh actually no I've been good right
you've been good you haven't been
gambling nope I've been I've been having
gambled in a minute oh [__]
get ready Marty
get ready ready
go all right Marty
everyone out there if you're listening
on Spotify watch the video if you're
listening on Apple can't watch an apple
thing come to YouTube that was usual
podcast why are you out here taking
[__]
CBD dabs okay there we go
oh we got some anxiety OG or OG
panic attack and [__] yeah
I'm just having a panic attack what a
bad example what a trash excuse I can't
believe you I'm actually gonna uppercut
you later at your home like that
oh
Marty got taken aback a little I haven't
seen Marty be affected by dad in the
morning [__] Morty's be taking Deb
that way no bro my Rex [__] I've never
seen you actually be affected
this person Oh you mean first time oh
[__] never seen him [__] Marty he's
got those [__] cold cold weather
loans
all right Marty oh it was a camera check
okay we'll leave we'll let you have that
one
it was a camera check it wasn't a get up
and breathe Marty why are you camera
checking can you get some Q-tips over
there
they're right behind Rosie [__]
morning oh gee
you have any other stories of you being
[__] heartless
oh harness do you have any other stories
of you being heartless toward humans
thank you
no not at all what do you mean you told
the man to shut up as his leg came off
what else did you do
as you were stealing someone's car
you're a nice guy
oh [__] what happened there oh Marty's
dead
yeah Marty died
yo Marty is left in the room
we finally got him guys
finally oh you ain't got water oh we
didn't get water so wow that's the first
time we've done that before good morning
so we're back we're back guys we're back
this episode is us just hanging out
smoking we with OG talking [__]
not really doing anything honestly I
like it this is garage talk hi OG
[__]
[__] water
[__] this [__] water you can open it
that was [__] little country yeah I
know be careful it will cut you
how you feeling
great that was the first one they got
you that's a big [__] dab
and we're back and we're back
so Marty
I know you said you wanted to ask coach
something I can't remember what it was
because I got off topic and now I'm high
as hell
um
good morning we talked about it before I
love Mike Tyson's podcast one time
uh he was just lighting a joint I told
you
I'm like Marty I'm gonna do that to you
one day one time Marty uh Mike Tyson has
this this had this co-host a huge buff
white dude that giant man whoever he was
uh he was dope though and Mike Tyson has
a podcast and he has a co-host and he
was just getting high smoking a joint I
thought it was the funniest [__] ever he
looks at his co-host whoa that shit's
stuck that's not good
that's weird he looked at his co-host
as Mike Tyson's lighting the joint and
the guest sits down and they start to
talk and my Tyson goes hey
ask him some [__] and then he starts
lighting this joint up it was a funny
[__] I ever saw in my life like yo I
love this man so much like no no well I
like this joint hey ask him some [__]
remember when I sat down in his [__]
chair not even thinking about it yo dude
when we got some Malcolm media because
you'll be filmed in the same Studio yeah
this fool decides to sit down
in Tyson's chair not thinking about it
just sits down in the throne we're not
even there yet I look at him do this
I was like what happened
is it on is the phone on oh shit's got
service it's just scary as [__] and then
he goes
he's a struggle Marty are you really
gonna sit in my Tyson's chair and take a
picture and he goes oh [__] he gets out
he goes I was going live
oh [__] so you so they were the [__] was
happening when you got there no the
set's right there we were just looking
at the set so you mean the set was about
to happen you this one just came in and
sat there you sat there right we were
there for a meeting so like we never
really knew especially early on like
when Tyson's gonna be there yeah we're
just we just saw the set we're like oh
sick picture
it was like the second time ever we had
even been there yeah I already sat in
the [__] Throne of all Thrones to get
punched on
I was about to go live
but good morning what happened there was
Italian no one said [__] no I showed
some [__] respect and got up
and went to the car I told him like
Marty are you really gonna sit there and
take a picture he goes oh [__] I told
him
I thought he was kidding bro are you
really gonna sit so you didn't even know
that no it didn't dawn wasn't paying
attention at all I think never even
crossed my [__] money
yeah yeah
try to Alpha him in his studio and ship
I said in his chair how much money would
it take for you to do a two minute round
with Tyson
right now if someone was like I got a
checkbook and I own oil fields I want to
see you fight Mike Tyson how much is it
going to cost [__] bro I would have to
say real fight real fight like he's
gonna two minutes three years
he's gonna go at you okay are you
kidding me I want [__] 20 mil 20 okay
okay
but what if he came at you and said the
mill
I'm surprised more people don't die but
you could get knocked out in five
seconds and then the fight's over
well I guess then maybe that'd be
different then you're getting knocked
out yeah punches could just [__] just
[__] end your [__] home life right
there of course you can't be handicapped
or some [__] or you didn't smoke any of
your joints he still moves right like
when he even just like plays around I've
seen it on podcast sets and [__] the way
he dips and slips and [__] is exactly
the same it's so scary he does this one
ah it's like you know when uh when uh
lawn you ever see the videos of
lawnmowers like getting out of control
and they start whipping they have to hit
it with a shirt to try to make it that's
him moving
would you [__] get in there and he
winds up you know it's like a Winder
winds up and [__] he has more than a
regular human did you I don't know if
you showed me this or if I've been
meaning to show you did you ever see the
neck workouts he used to do that's why
his neck hurts his head do you know what
I'm talking about disgusting you ever
see anything like weights and [__] no
you scorpion your neck and your back on
the canvas yeah later back what lay on
your back then you push your arch your
back up on your feet adjust your heads
on the ground and you swivel your whole
body weight on your neck bro while on
your back you don't even people do the
arch no arms though just your head wait
how lay on your back yeah and then push
your neck up so your your back's off the
ground yep and then your arch and he's
just rolling his neck huh I can't
explain it any better or more of them I
don't know how to do it I don't know how
to do it without doing it yeah
it's like here's your body
you never understand [__] so I was like
yeah I don't know if I could do it again
without hurting my actual neck I'll put
a video or a [__] picture up over the
screen but all right we got you
I'm gonna take a dab
um
damn we just how long we've been here
man two almost two hours good [__] we
just been sitting you're not doing [__]
I like it and this is like a current
episode the shit's coming out in the
[__] yeah you're getting high
actually I'm gonna give OG this [__]
fat dad again no I'm just kidding I'll
take one I'll take it
I'm gonna take one right now
sure nice one
he's a nice one Yo Joe uh OG's older
brother Mindy do you know who Joe
Piscopo is
the guy used to be on Saturday Night
Live Joe pissed what Joe Piscopo looks
just like your brother
it's kind of crazy
Joe Piscopo in the 90s though with the
hair
do it like a younger version of him when
he's kind of tan there's tan versions of
him he looks just like OG's brother dude
it's kind of awesome smoke away with him
last night was funny as hell
huh right here oh yeah that dude that
dude right there lift it up show him
look
brother bro
that looks like your brother
your brother's white as [__] he looks
just like him
sorry I here you go sorry one second
boom all right my bad guys we're here
taking tabs and [__] it's like second
time in a row we're just getting high on
an episode hey everybody did you like
last last week's episode because we
didn't really do a podcast Let's get
high as [__] with microphones there
that's pretty much what the episode was
I thought it was fun
I thought it was super I thought it was
perfect way to [__] open up our new
season back yeah
all right all right all right oh gee
what shows you watching right now
um
shows I think we started I got into that
one uh what's it called uh you tell me
watching that one it's called a pinky
Blinky peaky blinders yeah
I [__] been watching that [__]
you hear Joey Diaz is retiring from
podcasting
what per himself yeah he said that um
like pretty recently cool uh Joey Diaz a
comedian I showed you a lot of his [__]
yeah he's like I don't know Rogan's boys
older me
yeah he's okay really big on like
YouTube and Shred but he's a became a
super famous comedian he's hilarious
he's the guy I showed you uh the guy
told stories he beats his [__] out of
the nun the big big big Italian guy
yeah
all right so he retired so he had a
really big podcast that
was what I listened to coming up called
church and what's happening now that had
a very similar fan base to our families
like same type of [__] very similar show
they were like and it's so cool that
just to be able to do this now because I
always used to watch their show like
damn it's so [__] cool how they do it
and we kind of do it just like that
but then they he moved back to New
Jersey when the pandemic happened but he
started a new podcast out of his
basement but then he just went out and
just said basically modest story is not
feeling it anymore it's too much effort
my my podcasting days are done
it's got to be damn near [__] you're
like 1960. and you got to really
appreciate the fact he's that first
generation of like podcasters who've had
a real career run if you look back it's
been 10 15 years
you know so like like uh like a musician
or like uh you know
athlete or I don't know
I guess so that's pretty sad it was
weird
huh was he that good Joey Diaz yeah he's
one of the best all time he's great on
the planet he's one of the best like
storytellers just wild personalities
people always say I'm the younger him
because I talk mad [__] and tell stories
his stories are good and his ability to
get you fired up the [__] I mean I would
think like [__] I was still going right
yeah
you can he should I mean right it's a
certain personality type that can go
forever yeah you're right like there's
people that mainly you know like there's
people that can just talk about anything
and there's people that can only talk
about certain things and they just look
in their room yeah you're just more of a
the Howard Stern is like the most
unicorn you know like the rarest Rogan
where they can just go he's like that
talk about some nothing while dabbing my
bad guys my bad Howard Stern can't
[__] do all
oh hell no
you think you do no I didn't take a dab
right in front of you right now
don't worry son because I'm a [__]
badass
hey are you gonna which one do you want
to waste a tattoo which one you're gonna
not smoke all the way uh can we should
break it the smaller one yeah
listen to that I'll take the smallest
one because I won't finish my little
joint I'll take this one because what
the [__] man oh why'd you roll that one
someone you rolled [__]
look at the tip of that that's how you
twist your joints
look at the end of The Joint and tell me
you didn't roll that that is the way you
[__] roll your joints man I can even
see that wait a minute but you I might
do anything
I didn't do anything those I wrote
Because I burned this one these are not
even burned yeah you see the burn marker
these conviction though no burn on any
of those
what are you trying to say to me
there's no burn look at his face
no it is
so if they were his they'd be burned is
that what you're saying no I know
because I usually bring the tip off
there so you taste Char it's real it's
dope it's [__] it's [__] hey do me
a favor sit like straight-ish with your
mic because we can I can I can I hear
you like this
there you go no the mic so far there you
go right there oh my God we can hear
your voice
sing I just can't wait to be king from
uh Lion King
can we talk about what happened to your
vehicle
oh oh what I did to it damn you said it
says yeah you said it's scary what
happened
oh [__] uh I got my car back finally
yesterday so stoked let's go okay what
are you gonna do what's going on
okay that's the first thing that you've
ordered that hasn't been a complete hell
experience
and sometime
I mean I know it's about to be but I got
my car wrapped
the money
and that engine is re it's rebuilt
what do you mean Monte Carlo's engine is
rebuilt it's getting redone right now
same engine same engine rebuilt no I
they wanted to keep the originals
because it's so dope still we rebuilt it
it's gonna be it's gonna be no more
carburetor [__] where I have to pump
my pump my gas through the line to do it
okay everything's gonna be brand new
that basically [__] press to start
push to start over here and now let's
engine in it no same thing same engine
they're changing all the components you
cannot ask me car shakes I have no idea
what to say oh okay how about this sorry
if you like a GTA Chop Shop I press
change motor
all right
so anyway wrapped the car last night or
yesterday finally got it back and I told
you before and I'll tell the camera as I
walk up uh to get my car I drop Seinfeld
you know
I walk up to get my car and I walk in to
pay the lady and I walk out it's like
one of the technicians will be out I'm
like cool I'm walking out when the
technicians coming up my key goes
it's you
like damn he goes I was wondering why it
smelled so much like [__] weed in
there and I laughed and he goes I watch
your videos man it's awesome I didn't
know whose car this was I'm really glad
that it's yours and then another
technician came out
and
walk in my car he goes That's the guy yo
there's your ashtray is completely full
to the top and go oh I'm so sorry
because dude your car stinks and that's
what he said like we aired it out
yeah and then the guy that recognized me
at first he's like man I watch I watched
you with my homies and [__] it's like
[__] yeah this is and then he drove off
in a sick ass car like like a [__]
racer car like damn that is cool man and
then I I left
that's it whole [__] story so now is
is your rap story complete
um let's just say
there's a part of it that they didn't do
great but it's so minimal it's like this
ready
see this joint
that part's messed up
just that minute that much is messed up
and I'll notice it yeah for the rest of
life I could do this and be looking it
from this side and all I keep thinking
about is this bird yeah
and it's a super expensive joint
s
yes exactly it's yeah yep
this it was so I'm gonna have to reduce
the part apparent was a ceramic plated
joint oh and after I did the part where
they met okay so so what happened is
there's a part of the light and behind
since it's a Maybach it's the light logo
you know you take the logos off when
they wrap this logo is attached in the
middle to the light so that they did
when I walked up they told me like oh so
we didn't take it off we just cut pieces
and filled in your logo I'm like okay
you've done this before I'm sounding
light and I look like oh yeah we didn't
get it perfectly
oh
and I was a very nice it's like oh okay
appreciated my whole head a long time
I'm like sometimes get this fixed [__]
that sucks you say when you paint it you
just say well you know here's the money
but you know it's not perfect
I'm gonna have to try this anyway anyway
so
and I played the Lion King did you play
it off or did you let them know you were
like what the [__] no because I was like
yo you can't really see it that much
you're right if you're this close you
see it and I get this close because I
just paid you
so and then I found something else in my
trunk earlier and it really it's okay
it's so minimal you have to be like with
a magnifying glass to see it but like
bro you know you're with a magnifying
glass yeah it was Triple the first one
because I got the P I got the ppf I got
ppf coding on it which is like a
protective coating on the whole car and
then I got it wrapped and then I got two
cram ceramic coats of it on and after
that [__] is sealed and then now I have
to unseal it to fix two little pieces
and that little piece right here is a
whole panel that goes from the trunk to
the [__] Hood
but they were really nice the rest of it
looks immaculate anyway car's done and
now I need new different Wheels
everywhere you go bro it's gonna [__]
be like that
it seems seemingly I don't know I mean
looking if he wanted to make the scene
and [__] cause I will show he
wouldn't have his car right now though
yeah another [__] seven days ago or
whatever and it would redo it right yeah
but you know it's up to the person who
wants to complain and [__] once well
I'm not gonna have them fix it they
didn't want to do that in the first
place I'm gonna go somewhere because
okay no I'm pretty sure they'll fix it
if you tell me hey well I'm not paying
for this [__] this [__] I don't just
like well they would have they would
have took it out
my bad we're gonna [__] take well
look they would have did it in the first
place they said No it's it's we can't do
that that's what they said we can't take
that out we take the whole car apart on
the side
that's what they said they're like oh so
but then you talked about somebody else
somebody else said no the light is going
to break every time you take the light
out he's like I buy an extra light and I
break your [__] light out I wrap your
car and put the new light in like it's
[__] minimum cost so it is a standard
no he's like it's a [__] pain in the
ass but if you have that car why
wouldn't you [__] do it anyway Bowden
shout out to Boden they're gonna do my
car John gets all his cars done there
and we asked him three weeks ago hey can
you wrap the car and he goes I'm just
real busy right now blah blah blah we
called him and let him know what
happened with the rap and he's like why
didn't you come to me wait you said you
were busy guys I didn't say I wouldn't
do it I said I was busy I said I would I
didn't say I would do it did I
[__] yeah you're right so I would have
did that [__] I'm just busy right now
why are you giving me riddles yeah
he's gonna help me he's gonna fix it
um and I'm gonna I'm gonna do a couple
more things to it
so what are you doing I'm gonna get
these big Captain America rims
they're like big plates instead of
Champagnes they're just Locs yeah blue
glasses
yo what if I got o and a g o and a g on
the front but when you drove it said go
when I was in Reverse I said oh gee
women oh
what did you say
so you get your daddy's name on it no
you know be sick to get rims and get
them you know how low riders get their
rims etched
you know what I'm saying they get all
the Chrome etched oh like they tattooed
yeah yeah be sick on a newer car just
the rims be edged
Maybe
that'd be kind of Imagine them on your
on your car
everything no yeah I know but it'd be
kind of hard on your [__] like on one
lip of your Rim all edged out
probably this pattern all over the rim
um
do this joint you're us joins Urus
what's up OG what's on your mind man we
got these joints here boy you gave me
that [__] dab actually I know she
could be feeling [__] crazy I can't
[__] feel my chest no I'm good
that's great on a mid podcast I haven't
done this in a while
well huh
he knew he knew he knew he knew he just
put the joint down because he was scared
no actually this tip sucks that's what
she said look at all the joints he
didn't finish that's crazy we're in the
middle of an episode by the way guys I
just had to put this fool on a pool
that's it you watch that later on
Snapchat
what hilarious you didn't finish any of
your joints that's crazy well dude you
had like about what five different
flaves right no two was it two different
flavors one was Jack or whatever it was
and one was all the purple from London
so yeah like is my third one
that's one two three joints that's yours
okay that's your fourth one you're not
gonna finish all right no it's because I
don't finish him but you know once they
get down to the bottom right now it's a
little too too much resin when I got a
little fresh joint next to me how many
joints you smoking does if you smoke a
[__] 100 drinks and then no what are
you doing crack sodas open sips and
throws them down because you disappear
there's a fresh one you know like a
PeeWee Herman everything oh
I'm so
maybe a quarter at the most five and a
half so cool well you said how many
joints not looking at how much weight
yeah quarter wave about a quarter about
three joints four joints maybe not a
quarter equal
good joints that's fair I'm gonna go
down to La you're all yeah it depends if
I'm alone it's different you know what I
mean but if I'm with like people and
friends oh [__] you heard that yeah yeah
[__] an ounce today that's not true
it's a lot so I have to clean up for my
child yeah it could be a lot
sorry OG my bad my bad so everybody out
there
OG's out here
letting Fool's legs fall off
our friends legs are falling on that's
you oh I just can't get over that anyway
you saw some other fool get shot you
said and it was funny you saw him
shooting shot in the forehead
oh no that was one of my boys yeah they
see anybody else get shot with the 22
wait his brother in the bottom of his
foot oh yeah your brother got shot in
the foot that's right I won't say oh
you know I won't even say it I know a
human being that told me this I think I
might have said this
they they haven't been on the podcast
ever this is a person that I know
and they were like yo man I was fighting
this fool one time he's all he was like
six two his black dude with a bandana
like over his face and I was like all
right cool he's like
craziest fight I ever been I'm like okay
cool we said that you set the scene well
imagine the dude he's like yeah he's all
blue I'm like oh wow he's like I was out
of Bowl now it's like 19 I'm like damn
he goes yeah I couldn't beat his ass so
I pulled out my 22 and I shot him I made
me like six seven times in the chest and
he kept beating the [__] out of me and I
just ran away
she said I just emptied my little 22 and
he said the fool was like what the [__]
and he said it's good beating the [__]
out of me it's like 22 and that's why I
said 22 suck because I was 22 stuff to
do [__] you know that's the day I
stopped carrying 22. I was [__] 18 or
19. oh no [__] that was a kid right
I don't know probably not no probably
probably
I mean he said he's a big dude but he's
like dude and he get beaten the [__] out
of me that was the funniest story I've
heard about the 22s that's horrifying
that is scary it feels on PCP yeah
everyone have finished your joints cop
videos where they're like three tasers
don't work dude barely it doesn't even
feel it oh yeah they do [__] oh never
mind my brother rest in peace my my my
my cousin [__] um he got shot [__]
twice or yeah twice an arm and he just
pulled up too in this [__] car and
boom [__] [__] no actually he didn't
even pull up so car drove straight to
the hospital
[__] just showed up after [__] all
bad
we're like what the [__]
showed up bandaged up yeah we're like
damn fooling he just said yeah same [__]
[__] they just ran up on him [__]
you know but I forgot I just drove
myself you know I mean [__] it you know
[__] fat little hot he said but he
goes [__] it
but I don't know I guess that's why I
[__]
we gotta say
[__] been crying out there for
a [__]
dangling League
[Laughter]
because he got shot went to the hospital
and that was it well hey
at least drove himself right oh that's
what you were trying to say I'm like yo
what was the story like oh he drove
himself got you
well yeah no that's just scary as hell
that's just mad
very well it's so hard to talk about
certain things like yo I know a human
being I may or not be related to you
know I mean because then you're like you
probably know this guy it's not like a
story you made up
there's just so many stupid stories uh
somebody I know that's related to me I
remember he came to my house like full
[__] I'm like you look ghost white what
is wrong with you oh my God right by the
track I was selling [__] but
somebody I know used to uh sell Chris
right by the by the track on 20th or
21st some percent I don't know the
ghetto part 28th right by prestige's
house so like 20th I can't know the
street anyway we're Tweakers chill
there he came to my house and he looked
all pale he's sweaty I'm like yo what
the [__] just happened and then he
explained to me goes so so this is what
happened
I was selling this sack to this fool
that I know to his car and he tried to
take off on me so I know this
[__] tweaking ass fool and it's
like what do you think I did so I busted
my [__] out and everything's not
clipping his [__] in his car as he
drove off
he goes calls me that guy calls my
person that I know
pissed
justifially you know shooting at me he's
like my [__] kid's in the car and his
[__] baby was asleep like his
three-year-old was like laid out in the
backseat asleep didn't get hit but my
homie was like about to throw the [__]
up like so distraught he's like I almost
[__] kill the cat he was all [__]
up and it's I'm only laughing because I
was like bro this is what you did to
yourself you didn't of course you didn't
look in the backseat when you're selling
a sack when you ran off but the fact
that he almost shot a child over like a
[__] 20 sack is crazy could have shot
a kid over here I got shot out with my
nephew really okay oh yeah wait when
he's young yeah when you're still a
little baby he was not his fault oh no
he was about [__] about maybe about one
years old
and I want to go pick him up to bring
him back to my iPad
and I'm driving back and I drove back
and I drove to the neighborhood and I
got spotted I guess and
well you know what boom they pulled up
on me
at a stoplight this is [__]
[__] lit me up
from the side uh from the back
that sounds funny [__] I just I just
the first thing I did was just [__]
covering up and boom drove off
but for some reason [__] no bullets
[__]
hit us there's holes everywhere and [__]
none of this is not one
he out drove off came back to the pad
but can actually I pulled up to my that
was actually my girlfriend's pad back in
the day my ex-girlfriend I put him to
repair and [__] got my little nephew
out the car they took him inside the
house I took off
you know me
but yeah it was pretty scary though
after that I didn't realize that you
know
I should have been more grateful my
nephew didn't get shot you know he was
only one years old
she's crushed back then they used to
dance it out he went back and let him
have it meaning like windmill on
Windmill on Windmill on Windmill
headstand
and loser gets shot no through they're
still down they're still down losing
this good shot it's a duel to the death
all right blades on the feet yeah damn
now the car wash and shit's open yeah
we're gonna hit the car wash you know
what I mean the [__] are you talking
about what the [__] are you talking
about these guys when I got when I got
chased down they were having a car wash
you know my bad I didn't explain that I
got it I drove through I guess it was
like a car where I didn't also a car
wash but I drove to a neighbor and it
was a car washer bam I got spotted and
they followed me from there and that's
how [__]
I didn't even know I was being followed
so I just [__] back to the where you
went back to the car wash
[Laughter]
damn it's like that I got spotted that's
the definition
I got caught slipping you know not even
that it's like what are you doing today
oh [__] that's a guy I don't like you
should probably try to kill him
you got to be a real loser to be like yo
I got [__] to do bro I think I was only
I think I was 16. bro yeah
straight loser [__] for sure what the
[__] yeah I mean my thinking was just
like you weren't you weren't 16.
I'm the same age as your nephew
well maybe if he was one because I
remember I remember I was driving I was
driving I was driving the car and I
didn't have a license I was 14 turning
15. if he was a year yeah you're right
we started driving at 13. same same age
yeah 13 years old I started driving
is that Mexican [__] yeah
uh nah actually [__] we're all [__] up
and everybody's drinking and they just
said hey you know they're driving me
trying to show off in front of the
ground I said yeah I know how to drive
they put me to drive bro and I didn't
know how to [__] drive
hold on explain the night what's the
setting where are you when this happens
um where in East Delhi he's telling
exactly you know what right around
freaking right there [__] uh what is
it uh Boyle Heights right there by Cinco
puntos they say other [__] by the
cemeteries the big one they should have
said that got you we're over on that
side of town you know what I mean and
ever drinking and you know I was so
young and they just everybody's all
[__] up and I was drinking myself
so I mean I was [__] up too so they
just said and they yeah I mean they
didn't think I was that drunk because
you know I was [__] really [__]
drinking so I didn't know how much to
drink I was just [__] pounding one
two three beers and that's it
and [__] it drove back freaking uh who
could drive and I was like I don't know
how to drive us they're like all right
you're driving and then [__] well I just
remember [__] it felt like I mean
back then it felt like a damn [__] I
was driving in a [__] like a boat
like just [__] everything was big man
I was just like [__] and you know moving
out there like oh [__] but they were
drunk they didn't even know the [__] I
was [__] I was over here [__] [__]
dude I was swerving everywhere bro and
they didn't know because they were
[__] up too and then not only that but
they were like everybody was just
laughing in the car I remember you know
everyone laughing because I was over
here [__] almost on some busy ass L.A
streets oh no on this one no I'm talking
driving 12 in the morning it's two in
the morning's house not far all right
two in the morning so yeah oh no from
that side of town to my to my pad it's
about
I wish we had an animator as you were
saying this whole story I don't know if
it's because my mom and dad were drug
addicts
but my brain was above us thinking of
some [__] as I was in the story all I
kept thinking is this little
OG and it pans over him with like that
Dr Seuss and little OG he takes his job
you know I was thinking of little him as
narrating this little drunk little boy
and I was thinking whoa what if we had
an animator of this fool and it was like
who feels Style cartoon we need an anime
if you're an animator and not just hey I
can draw nah bro if you can make a
cartoon we'll pay you if you can make a
cartoon tell us because I would love to
animate that we got a good candidate
remember oh but for cartoon animation
yeah remember the dude with the uh oh
the guy that emailed us yes okay what
happened to yours I haven't seen you
post that one right don't you have one
cartoon cartoon
I did that one for like three four years
ago yeah it was like 40 seconds is that
that one right that's four years ago
probably the only one you do go
everywhere
oh okay so it was like supposed to be
one of many but it was just one of one I
would love to get the animator on that
one just little OG and then his socks
Rose higher as he got to the car that Dr
Seuss does that [__] yeah
stash grew in by the end of the drive
thank you
that's the mission to accomplished
respect
said was not out but just dude I can
make a whole book on you right now Dr
Seuss Style
yo somebody animated that for us or
little OG with socks up to his neck
slickback hair socks his neck
one sock bottles
yo remember when you didn't finish any
[__] joints you just put it down
again
right now I might want this one right
you always want your kids to do better
than you and I'm sorry I don't get that
luxury in life my son's failing not
doing very good right now
so I'm taller than you did we ever
address when uh how he missed
opportunity when he got pulled over
and you were in the back seat and the
cop tried to tell try to Sun him yeah
did we bring that up in front of OG what
that he had the opportunity to be like
oh that's my son sorry I just look it I
wasn't looking
oh yeah I wasn't looking I was looking
my joint was on fire I just
burned my fingers so severely it hurts
Charter but look how black
[Laughter]
that hurts so bad it's not coming off
I've burned my nails I burned how big
burn the [__] out of myself with this
[__] torch lighter yeah oh wow hey
um yeah remember when you're getting
pulled over he's like go tell your kids
yeah you did yeah he's like you should
have been like sorry my son my grandkids
will hear about it Thomas was in the
back seat
he just told me get the [__] out of here
go tell the kids what you were doing he
said get the [__] he went like that
in a little a little sauce
he took it he was fine with it yeah he
didn't care I just [__] drove off
while he was as he was lecturing him he
just slowly turned OG's hat around yeah
go tell your [__] kids
[__] roll it up like he's from Santa
Cruz it's [__] little lip bro he
broke your hat oh yeah what happened
were you disgusted
what went through your head when he said
that I want you to go home and tell
yourself [__] it I mean you got it you
got it good I'll tell him that for sure
I'll let them know you know I did when I
got home I was like look it's I'm
driving through the kids let's take it
[__] up today the day I learned yo
we've been here for two and a half hours
almost wow a little good little little
episode of nothing my favorite we talked
about nothing I love it nothing I love
it we talked about nothing which is the
best episodes ever you had a great quote
you're like we talk about nothing but we
give a [__] about it there you go yeah
we talk about nothing but we care about
what we're talking about sure a lot of
people are just talking about nothing
but yeah you just
I'm just talking [__] I think it's funny
I really burned my finger it's pretty
cool all right I [__] with that OG what
are you doing right now huh not post on
Instagram you don't make no videos
actually I do it posted my story you
don't [__] dunk on no more well you
know actually dude I've been I've been
out there taking down a lot of pictures
from my Instagram
reporting them and [__] so you know I
don't want to lose this one so I'm like
[__] I don't know
I just posted on my story it's like the
fifth episode you always Grill them
about this at the end so many times you
talked about this screen it's 45 minutes
[__] me [__] I'll be there forever
yeah
I'd rather just keep it cool just
posting the story instead of [__] hit
that putting actual post get your joint
you gotta just post you talking [__] to
your employees and [__] just hold the
camera out yeah lots of other things you
should do a fitness page
real Fitness you should do a fitness
page but it's you talking [__] to
somebody doing Fitness and how to do it
I like that there's a [__] ass push-up
yeah watch this
for sure that sounds like a good one
like you've been firing the [__] out of
people lately yeah fired a few [__] you
ran a fireman's free last time you were
here the last time I called him before
this the day before this he answered the
phone uh [__] fire bring it here I
wanna let me fire it
Jesus Christ
[__] dick [__] well she's not
doing her job I get it but like don't be
so enthusiastic yeah you're so
enthusiastic yeah yeah I'm a fire I have
someone else fire room
[Laughter]
what the [__]
you put the joint down again it's been
four seconds it's been four seconds just
[__] career
myself
um
all right cool cool well don't go follow
OG on anything
oh he doesn't have anything dirt he
doesn't do anything he doesn't do any
social put it down
[Music]
yo I'll smoke it I'll smoke this one too
real quick just to [__] show my son
up
is that a boy what's wrong with you and
a boy cowboy hey
[Laughter]
it's called heavy Indica heavy heavy
Indigo OG that's the name it's a long
name
it's called could be a height all right
yeah it was a silver haze it's called
can't be a hybrid
get those silver haze all right well
anyway dude a pinky ring is [__]
dancing in the life it is dancing
it is it was lost at one point it was so
sick oh gee you need to I told him the
other day he said Rock rings on every
finger break dancing and then enough
rings on this thumb to go to the nail
and I think people respect you more you
should start doing those tick tocks
where you do crazy [__] with street food
because you have all the Rings yeah
everybody cool a picture of Jordan with
all the [__] yeah yeah like Michael
Jordan like that or one hand while
you're cooking [__] with kids as you
take the ice cream out of their clothes
like that my pinky ring I'll make you
some food and then you start [__]
food truck and do the tick tock [__]
you're just like slamming bread or you
see that guy that opens fruit and
screams that's you
there you go there you go
all right guys well
we've been here for a minute
oh my [__] couldn't tell you one thing
we talked to no no hit it there you go
you should smoke it I'm gonna Photoshop
OG and this turtleneck for the thumbnail
hey remember you somehow you're somehow
got all the way over there
[Music]
he slowly gets up and leaves
laughs
yo before can I show everybody
before OG guy here he text me this
he texts me this picture
and I I want to break it down with this
real quick before we start OG at 12 39
right he's supposed to be here at one
we showed up at two it's horrifying
um this is the picture he texted me an
hour and 20 minutes for you guys
[Laughter]
I don't know who it is
but he's actually this picture how do
you even come about it
no words but what I think is on this
face I see a person that's like this
slightly scared doesn't want to be on
camera and I think that's what you're
like I'm really nervous and that's why
you text me that did I break it down
right
why did you pick this picture and what
did you pick what is the word you typed
in
to get this picture and we'll say what
words you type in your phone to get that
picture on again did you put it nervous
but this is detected nervous I think it
just um just random [__] my humor I do
[__] [__]
my humor I do no you sent me this right
before we started this kid looks like he
doesn't want to be on camera no but I
always send you random pictures
I know what did this one mean it wasn't
right um a happy kid yeah all right
never mind you're alive you're trying to
get in your head I think he's alive he's
alive
The Wire
dude wait where's the other Joy he's put
it out what do you mean he smoked it up
bro
it's OG's daughter's birthday today this
man's over here
how could you waste weed on the day of
my daughter's birthday
it's some [__] this [__] six
grams in there because of this guy
[__] six grams of smokable weed in
there still
I'm gonna flick this to you and catch it
shoot it open your mouth wide and close
your eyes he's got the looks on his
friends hey block this camera again no
block the camera block the camera with
your whole chair again
Scoop from the on side of the table to
the other there you go abruptly there
you go laying your little road chip so
you don't say that's yours this is doing
you a favor
that's not true
he's a gentleman
really Marty
that's a fact I apparently smoke joints
way faster than I would
okay here we go here we go guys
we've been here for a minute thank you
guys so much for being here Marty do you
have anything look it you lit it up I'm
trying to pass in two seconds there you
go Marty
I don't want to see anything else you
want to ask OG we this is this episode
has been just us block the camera again
okay
just [__] cheer over
I appreciate it these are my favorite
[__] episodes I [__] like this
episode you know why
that guy right there on that camera that
guy
we made this easy
he's always on time made it easy
smokes all his weed tells stories of
human Human Excellence saving lives beat
all over you want to [__] oh I don't
want to hit that [__] damn Brody yeah
thank you so much
damn your daughter's birth we got the
[__] wolves coming in next Josh
Jake wolfer coming next week we got John
Hash House coming ringing high as hell
[Music]
but I'm just High
a soundboard's scary
I meant to hit
hey yo that's correct yo you
[__] Hash House episode
Ed bomb I thought you said that because
of the Butcher and I was like Mario that
was so funny this phone said inbound
[__] is that why we're getting flagged
of that because of that maybe bro baby
bleep it this time
bleep it while you're standing in your
house on the side of your house bleep
that all right here we go oh gee as you
drink water say something
foreign
[Laughter]
oh wow what's up what you got anything
else you want to say before we get out
of here man you know how you were
sitting there
[__] articulating your life and [__]
you just he wants everybody to come say
hi to him when they come in and ask for
him I use code OG or dtpg
zero percent off one chest bump right
and he'll do the thing where you guys
stand in front of each other stand on
one leg and you like lock ankles and and
dance and do the jump with the other leg
dance yeah what I'll give him 20 off he
was 20 off oh [__] but you gotta ask
roji he's gonna hate his life these live
forever these Hills are forever they
don't go
yourself
we'll see let's see he's going to say I
lied to 10 patients today
[Laughter]
I'm not here
exactly I'll do it she's gonna lie to
how many people knocking on the wall
so he doesn't have to get up and say hey
excuse me can you come here he knocks on
a wall so people hear it through the
other and he keep doing it just like
this it's a crazy [__] I've ever seen
they have earpieces I just have a
[__] walkie-talkie but then you just
do this and knock until somebody comes
and presses the belt hey LG
yeah
look how proud he was of it
oh answer yeah I told you the other day
or how long ago was it that his uh if
you just go like this on his face and
only look at his nose down it looks like
a little airplane or a t-shirt her hair
look at this look at this mustache and
then the wings it looks like a little
half a plane and or a t-shirts
[__]
oh she's like [__] you fool
I told him the other day I can't wait
whoa if you look it just says USA in
color Ops USA oh [__]
the card's a subliminals what the [__]
was that
how we never see that we found a deck in
the wall one time we did find a dick in
the wall oh gee look right underneath
the you
it was like a side of a little dick look
at the you and look at the wall right
underneath the U it's the color to you
and it looks like a little dick on the
wall in the corner and then if you look
at the Pizza next to it it looks like
little drips
it's terrible
yeah there's a little dick on the wall I
don't think anybody's ever seen that in
our people Easter egg
it's just it's just images lay overlay
overlay overlay and just for some reason
that cut off and it looks like a little
dick
it's funny but it does look like a
little dick with now the pizza is like
jizz
age restrict
and then if you look great down Homer's
just waiting
Homer's waiting down there he's just
waiting for the come on his face
he's never seen it
you guys can't see him from the angle
but underneath that dick drip about a
foot and a half there's an open home
like this with his mouth open it's
incredible look at him he's got to take
a picture of it
look at the [__] you see the dick trip
it's a Homer's mouth terrible
mid podcast we're talking about this
[__] uh OG anything else you want to
say you're gonna make a [__]
enchiladas you said
he said you start making medicated
enchiladas
enchilada you get more hyped and wired
so what are you gonna be doing anything
you want to save before we leave this
place
say what
um
what the hell man
something anything you want to say
before we got here
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
you wouldn't [__] give me your tabs
fool I give you one singular dad and I
knew that was it I was gonna do it more
toward the end but as you said I was
like damn half grab right now and then I
busted that up was the best [__] I can't
wait till Marty like soon
on your face
for sure
mathematical sense to me
so what's up well that's it you don't
want to say anything you don't want to
say like
anything crazy otherwise nothing crazy
you wanna say anything super super like
anti-political or anything crazy
sure she didn't want to see nothing
raider-esque
this was a raiderette certified
raiderette
I said raiderette
Raider rats are there cheerleaders here
oh look at this right in your frame what
does she want to say there you go what
do you want to say
blow up the candle Marty what do you
want to say we're about to get we're
about to leave is that all you want to
do
it's like you're posting that's what I'm
doing this bill's Raiders September 17th
Jesus Christ bills Raiders yeah let's go
let's all go damn September in Vegas in
rough buff oh never mind oh bless your
souls oh September in Buffalo yeah never
mind never mind
all right oh Jesus you have not a
[__] word to say apparently
apparently apparently
I've never been on camera before
that's this [__] right now
apparently you're supposed to talk
exactly Marty thank you you would have
heard the sound bite Marty just played
you just got dookie down you also I
don't know how but you had Ash in your
fingers you rubbed it all over your
[__] face it is the best go like this
wipe at least that we're gonna finish
the podcast why don't you tell me
anything
no you're good you're good I've had Ash
all over my face I really wanted Mario
live for me
as an ashy face [__] I got some
morals here come here
let me get you whoa let me hit you with
the little or the Ash Wednesday [__]
yeah I know it really look like a
[__] football player no I did that a
couple years on years ago on Twitter and
people got pissed off at me I've
recorded myself to step into action in
my graduate or my ashtray I did this
little
ended before I missed
it's funny it's funny I don't know what
that means you should do the Doobie dude
next time oh the little guy that I smoke
with or the little guy that I signed
with yo what's happening here what's up
guys
thank you guys we appreciate you we're
gonna get this [__] out we got
one day to do it one day turn back on
Tuesday
we're out here [__] working building
this [__] back up bigger better than
ever it feels great we appreciate
everybody
smashed on
you don't play anymore fool stop it you
don't even play all right you have
nothing to say right at all whatsoever
[Laughter]
I don't know you never know all right
we're gonna get here okay
so you sure you're good with that you
could if you had your headphones on you
would hear this hi I'm OG's mind and I
have checked out completely Jesus Christ
to the show
you a dab an hour into the show I have
no concept of how long ago that was
probably I'm just guessing all right but
also remember when Marty coffins yeah I
know prove that he actually is a [__]
human being with lungs
like it's like a game yeah you want to
see it's like I said it's like blowing
the air with the ball the DUI [__] yeah
foreign
guys this has been an episode-ish
of the dope as usual podcast we've just
been talking [__] basically in OG's
garage almost shooting Tony's in the
head but only shooting Oscar De La Hoya
poster that was today I'm so surprised I
remember that
that's what you told me you know that
remember you remember you told me the
story I knew he didn't know what I was
talking about one time I was with my
friend I was [__] with a gun I think
it was from Honduras or some [__] and I
was like damn look at this [__] and it
went off almost shot
you [__] you [__] that
was good time
he did a good shot you [__] bastard
here we go and if the gun went off one
time and almost shot my friend remember
I told you that story or no yeah I have
told you that sorry yeah did you get in
did that tell me no he did well I almost
shot my friend the bullet almost hit him
but it hit my poster on the wall Hoya
poster it hit the Australia right in the
head
Honduras yeah you're right on this one
still didn't recognize the story which
is awesome well no I was just kind of
tripping but you know what you have told
me a story about someone with a gun or
some [__] so probably kind of sound the
same yo there was a gun so it was the
same story you know we're High he's
telling me while we're High bro come on
you're high wait for a party
um it's okay man you're kidding you know
you're getting too like you're pube
people are changing your body's changing
you went through puberty recently you
started growing a little stash that
that's a Joe Dirt it doesn't move he
doesn't even shade
it's crazy no it's like it's a Lego
block if you pull it straight out at
night remembering paid in full when
Makai Pfeiffer taking off all his
jewelry yet and he folding shirts at
night
it clicks off like Mr Potato Head his
hat clicks had his head
clean it
you want to be walking around with [__]
in your mustache no you gotta get it
approach
that's that you know that's that's that
Jersey it splits on those other sides
like a GI Joe and it comes off
what one
you put it on clothes we need somebody
to draw that
please God somebody draw that you know
how to do the toy and then they do the
toy with your accessories next to all my
mock-ups we need OG and then we need OG
skinny with like his jersey next to him
with big big spaces under the shoes so
he's big
mustache yo this was one of the funniest
things I can ever think of holy [__] you
didn't think that was [__] hilarious
oh my God I did I I did
holy [__] he's got one of those Tequila
bottles
I said no more dabs for you
no more dabs for me I'm so sorry I keep
thinking of the [__] toy of this that
was amazing thank you for knowing you so
I can say that allowing me to think that
and that I could think it and just
process it
I'm so high
and hungry but actually not high I think
I was just coughing I mean laughing
really hard I got all light-headed
because I just looked up I was like oh
[__] probably the weed how you feeling
I'm pretty [__] lit all right cool
that's where we're gonna end this place
I said we're gonna end this episode
and [__] OG is actually 120
underneath that Jersey
[__] dead [__] [__] singular
death
all right we're gonna get out of here oh
geez Instagram so I can it exists it's
there
I'm not gonna say hey man go check out
this Fool's [__] artwork and you
don't do [__] anymore he used to do fun
stuff on Twitter he posted on Twitter
though
go follow OG's Twitter what's your
Twitter Twitter's just without the
underscore OG
o-g-e-e-k-u-s-h-76 no underscore
underscore go follow his Twitter you
post fun [__] on Twitter because you can
post weed thank you how about you post
more
add views on his [__] yeah and he's like
why don't you post on the place that
they're like yeah this is it well [__]
it's gonna be [__] I be getting
[__] we know that vacation you know
this that [__] had to take pictures
down so now oh we know that and
everything just go to Twitter we're
talking about yeah I think Twitter's a
lot better yeah you can post whatever
the [__] you want on Twitter I [__]
love Twitter yeah I just started kind of
paying attention to her recently it's
awesome just go on Twitter you post we
[__] and get high post bonus all the
time for sure yeah I touched my IO weed
I can feel it damn it damn it you made
it so I made it so far all right
um let's get out of here OG you bro did
you smoke all your drinks
anymore
although he was out of it it was crazy
Marty thank you so much for being here
appreciate it thank you oh gee thank you
so much for being here appreciate it the
first time you weren't
again super scared I'm not scared look
he was good this time you start talking
about [__] it was great
he came in here with his list of things
he wanted to talk about and we got to it
yeah we got a whole list of zero [__]
list it was sick guys thank you so much
for being here I appreciate it for
everyone else in this room hanging out
Rocco has been contact high probably for
three hours me and Rosie are hanging out
um
guys thank you so much for being here go
follow our Instagram right now before
you get out of here it's dope as usual
podcast it's probably over the screen
right now whoosh and then boom our
Twitter go follow that [__] too go
follow that [__] above all we need help
on the clips Channel we have to
circulate that [__] go watch the clip
channel it's dope as usual podcast Clips
boom over the screen go follow that we
took down every single video to get
monetized
because it was so explicit and then
right we took them all down they were
like well you don't have any videos so
you have no hours but shut up so we had
to do 4 000 watch time hours again and
we had we had a couple hundred thousand
or a million almost and uh on the clips
Channel and I was like wait because we
took down the explicit videos there's no
watch time so now we can't get monetized
at all so we did it to be monetized it
was the best thing ever yo give me that
give me that give me your life all right
cool
oh you better [__] get it
that was really good I loved it anyway
let's get out of here guys thank you so
much for being here we got a bunch of
bomb ass Pizza we just ordered I'm so
[__] hungry I'm stoked it's got the
dopest font
oh similar one too similar to The Dope
was fun yeah hot tub bomb ass piece of
spots vegan pizza spots by myself thank
you guys so much for being here I
appreciate it until next time guys this
has been the dope as usual podcast I
touched weed in my eye super super sick
I'm about to start [__] getting off
here
oh [__]
oh my God [__]
the other eye this time
it's so high
my eye hurts all right thank you guys so
much this has been another episode of
the dope as usual podcast until next
time I'm double Jola have a dope ass day
yeah this feels like the show I couldn't
end the show for 42 minutes yeah we're
here we're hanging out we're back
exactly three minutes on the board let's
go but we talked for nine minutes with
OG for nothing about nothing
so hey remember when you smoked no weed
that was cool yeah I remember remember
when you smoking no weed no you always
just repeated me
what do you mean licking they're all
done I smoked
juicers because they were halves do you
not remember you'll recall
I had to smoke your roaches because I
felt played you need to smoke it I
tasted all of them
[Laughter]
oh you can
[Music]
perfect
foreign